Wollte ich das im Moment wieder raus machen, chat?
Ja, also, gestern ist ja noch Hermes gekommen und mein Axis Point ist angekommen.
Also, der 444 aktueller Generation Axis Point, für irgendwie 70 Euro oder so auf Ebay.
Als ich mir gedacht habe, da kannst du nicht viel falsch machen, einfach mal ausprobieren.
Feature-mäßig ist es ungefähr so wie die aktuellen halt bloß kein Wi-Fi 6 und kein
Wi-Fi 5, sondern nur AC anstatt AX.
Kennt irgendjemand Wi-Fi Standards wirklich aus dem Kopf?
Ich krieg das nicht hin.
Ich weiß, AX ist das aktuelle und AC ist das davor, glaube ich.
Nee, AX ist das aktuelle, dann davor kommt was, was ich nicht weiß und AC kommt dann
davor.
Irgendwann kommt D und N und B und G und, ach, keine Ahnung, einer WLAN Standard aus
dem Kopf.
So ist es 802.11, aber ansonsten kein Schimmer.
Wer weiß sowas auch aus dem Kopf, wenn du es nicht jeden Tag machst.
Ein Beilad für jeden, der jeden Tag WLAN machen muss.
Ups, falscher Knopf, lull.
Das funktioniert übrigens wunderbar, was wir gestern im Stream gemacht haben.
Ich hab jetzt diese Konsole von der Wetterstation raus in den Flur gestellt und hab das, was
wir programmiert haben, auf den Raspberry Pi im Keller gehauen.
Einfach meinen Router umgebogen auf DNS Server der Raspberry Pi im Keller und jetzt funktioniert
es.
Also es hat wirklich, wirklich gut geklappt, also hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass das
so easy ist.
Ich mein, wir haben zwar gestern noch irgendwie dreieinhalb Stunden rumgemacht, aber das war
ja im Prinzip nix großartig kompliziertes.
Das war bisschen kämpfen mit meinem Access Point irgendwie eine halbe Stunde und dann
rumprobieren, aber die Sache ist halt die, ich bin ein weiteres Mal jetzt darin bestätigt,
dass ich China-Chinesen-Kram nicht einfach ins Internet hänge oder einfach ins normale
Netzwerk, was ich ins Internet kann.
Ich mein, wenn das erste ist, erstmal Baidu und Amazon auflösen, was das Ding macht,
von der Wetterstation, dann beißt ihr Bescheid, ne?
Und weil wir ja rausgeklickt haben, das ist ein reiner Online-Check.
Eigentlich ist das gar kein blöder Online-Check, Baidu und Amazon anpingen und gucken, ob's
funktioniert.
Für Online-Check.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich mein, der könnt auch einfach den vorkonfigurierten
Webservice nehmen und wenn der erreichbar ist, ist gut und wenn nicht, also der muss
gar keinen Online-Check machen, aber bei dem China-Chinesen-Zeug weiß man nie so genau.
Deswegen, ich bin da wieder bestärkt geworden, dass man China-Zeug nicht ins Internet hängen
will oder nicht ins normale WLAN hängen will und jetzt, mit dem neuen Nexus-Point, kann
ich auch eigene WLAN-Passwörter pro Endgerät vergeben.
Ich habs mir überlegt, die waren irgendwie bei 2000 noch was, 2300 oder so, die Aktie
von Amazon und ich habs überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach Just For Fun, weil ich halt
schon mal immer einfach mal eine Amazon-Aktie kaufe, weil es geht.
Ich habs mir echt überlegt, weil ich mein, die sind so krass getroppt, wie irgendwie
die letzten, keine Ahnung, seit Corona, die sind jetzt quasi fast so tief wie vor Corona,
eigentlich ganz, aber das ist richtig nach unten gegangen und das müsste eigentlich
auch wieder hoch gehen, aber man weiß es halt nicht, das ist halt das Ding, wenn man es
müsste.
Easy.
Ich glaube, ich hole mir eine Amazon-Aktie, einfach um eine Amazon-Aktie zu haben, aber
mein World-ETF ist auch POG, POG-G, not POG, not stonks, getroppt as fuck, aber gut,
es ist halt alles getroppt as fuck.
Das ist auch das Ding, wo ich mir immer so denke, gerade so Stammtisch-mäßig, es ist
ja immer so nach dem Motto, es wird alles teurer und jetzt bereichern sich alle daran
und uns geht es hier schlecht, aber wenn man sich mal die Aktienkurse anguckt, so wirklich
gut geht es aktuell keinem, ne?
Ich mein, es macht manchen mehr und manchen weniger, das will ich gar nicht bestreiten,
aber dass da irgendwie einer den Wahnsinns reibacht von macht, ist zumindest an den Aktienkursen
gerade nicht zu erkennen.
Investieren statt sparen.
Ja, also auf dem Stand bin ich zumindest jetzt, zumindest jetzt, naja, ich sag mal teilweise,
weil gerade bei aktuellen Inflationsraten, ich hab mich ja lange davor gedrückt, mal
mit meiner Kohle was zu machen, aber das pure Rumliegen ist einfach Paynes-Champ und es
ist wie bei vielen, wenn man anhand angefangen hat, denkt man sich, warum hast du das nicht
schon 10 Jahre früher gemacht, da hättest du jetzt Kohle gemacht, aber gut, man, das
hat ja keinen Sinn, sich da weiter Gedanken drüber zu machen, nachher bist du immer schlauer.
Wenn ich die Lotto-Zahlen von heute weiß, kann ich auch sagen, warum hast du gestern
nicht Lotto gespielt, ja, das funktioniert ja nicht, man muss das immer anhand der aktuellen
Entscheidungen, also Informationen, die einem damals vorgelegen haben, festmachen, weil
es ist auch genauso, wenn ich sag, hey, guck mal, stell euch mal vor, ich wäre derjenige
gewesen, der sich damals irgendwie von, keine Ahnung, 15 Bitcoin oder so die erste Pizza
gekauft hat, dann würde man sich auch denken, warum bin ich so dumm gewesen, hab ich's nicht
behalten und hab mir ne Pizza gekauft, aber das kannst du so nicht sehen, du musst sagen,
unter den aktuellen Bedingungen und den Informationen, die ich damals hatte, war das eine gute oder
schlechte Entscheidung, das konnte ja keiner ahnen, dass irgendwie 10 Jahre später das
eine Ding irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie viel ist das aktuell wert, 35.000 Euro oder so,
das weißt du ja nicht, keine Ahnung, wenn du das wüsstest, wärst du instantreich,
wobei instantreich wird man ja, wenn man einfach das richtige YouTube-Video guckt,
das weiß man ja, man muss einfach nur die richtigen Leute auf YouTube gucken, die zeigen
dir, wie man reich wird, aber nur, aber nur, wenn du ihren Kurs buchst, WhatsApp-Gruppe
ist aus, heutzutage musst du Kurse buchen, das ist alles so ein Schwachsinn, der Scam
ist so alt, ich verstehe nicht, warum immer noch Leute auf diese Scams reinfallen, die
Scams gab's 1905 oder so wahrscheinlich schon, aber halt noch nicht im Internet, sondern
auf der Straße, dass dir irgendeine Leute erzählt hat, ich zeig dir, wie du reich wirst,
und ich mein, guckt euch mal diese ganzen Schneeballsysteme an, oder es gibt ja, wie
nennt man das, Pyramidenschema-Dings, wie ihr wisst, was ich mein, guckt euch diese
ganzen Dinger an, das gibt's auch schon seit hunderten von Jahren und das klappt immer
noch, wir müssten eigentlich davon ausgehen, die Leute haben es langsam kapiert, aber ne,
die machen sowas immer noch mit, und teilweise ist das richtig abgefeiert, was da geht, naja,
egal.
Multilevel-Marketing, ah, das klingt natürlich noch viel, das klingt noch weiter weg davon,
und irgendwelche Scam-Sachen zu sein, das klingt natürlich, es ist immer wichtig, dass
wenn man Leute scammt, dass man das nicht so nennt, dass die Leute merken, dass sie gescampt
werden.
Naja, so, Leute, habt ihr irgendwelche interessanten Videos, die wir uns heute zu Gemüde führen
müssen?
Ich hab zwar genug noch offen, aber da ist jetzt nichts dabei, wo ich sag, das muss ich
unbedingt gucken, das ist so super krass, mega spannend, wer das schon immer sehen
wollte.
Ähm, wir refreshen mal, die Masken-Sache, welche Masken-Sache, ach, das da, legit,
ich hab, ich habe nicht mitbekommen, was da ist, was ist da eigentlich, ich ignoriere
so YouTube, generell so Krempel eigentlich, mittlerweile komplett, ich hab den Namen paar
mal gelesen, ich hab keine Ahnung, eigentlich muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, interessiert
mich absolut gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt ist mir das auch total egal, was da wieder läuft.
Warum kriege ich Overwatch-Videos empfohlen?
Sechs Stunden Overwatch, nee, nicht wirklich, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel, das
ist gut, naja, wem auch immer es geht, sie stellen es wahrscheinlich nicht aus 3D-gedrucktem
Material her und wahrscheinlich etwas in etwas anderer Fertigung als jemand, der daheim
mal kurz, aber gut, was auch immer, aber generell sind Ersatzteile viel zu teuer, das stimmt
schon, weiß nicht, ob es in dem Video darum geht, keine Ahnung, ich will es auch nicht
sagen, aber Ersatzteile sind teilweise viel zu teuer, ich hab letztens geguckt für meinen
Ofen, wollte ich eine Ersatzlampe haben und ihr müsst wissen, der Ofen ist keine Ahnung,
20 Jahre alt oder so, oder 15 Jahre alt, und ich wollte eine Ersatzlampe haben und da braucht
man irgendeine Speziale, ich glaube Siemens Lampe oder so, dass sie da reinpasst und die
wollten irgendwie 65 Euro haben für eine Mini-Lampe für den Ofen, so, 65 Euro, ich glaube es geht
los, das Ding, das kostet irgendwie 2 Euro oder so normalerweise, gut, also mal geguckt
und anscheinend kann man auch von anderen Herstellern was reinmachen, das kostet dann
irgendwie 5 Euro, funktioniert genauso gut, aber ich hab es nicht gemacht, lasst das Ding
einfach ohne Lampe, ich brauch keine Lampe für, Tauri in 100 Sekunden, ok, das gucken
wir uns an, ist Tauri nicht dieses Elektron Ding, dieses Elektron Ding, was nicht Elektron
ist, ich muss mal kurz was gucken auf GitHub, wie, hat das Microsoft jetzt eigentlich geschafft,
ach, das haben sie jetzt umbenannt, das haben sie jetzt, mein WinUI 3 ist immer noch nicht
fertig, sollte das nicht eigentlich rauskommen, letztes, vorletztes Jahr, Ende 2020 oder
so, ey Microsoft und Desktop UI Kram, die kriegen den Kräppel echt nie gebacken, oder,
ist das schlecht, Alter, wie kann es, guck mal, Apple und ich bin jetzt nicht der größte
Apple Fan, aber eins kriegen die hin, die haben konsistente Desktop bzw. GUI Frameworks,
die klappen, die funktionieren, die gescheit aussehen, die man verwenden kann, warum kriegt
das Microsoft nicht gebacken, nein WinUI ist nicht WPF, WinUI ist quasi das, was UWP an
GUI Technologie hatte, weiterentwickelt und eigentlich so gebaut, dass man es mit allen
Anwendungen verwenden kann, also nicht nur UWP und die kriegen es nicht geschissen, das
ist echt der Wahnsinn, ich weiß nicht, wie Microsoft so unfähig sein kann, ich meine,
kein Wunder, na, Maori ist Müll, Maori ist quasi Xamarin Forms mit den Bugs von vor 5 Jahren
mit ihrer komischen Philosophie, dass man Native UI Frameworks rappt und so, das ist
Krap, Alter, ich hab mir mal Just For Fun Tutorial Kurs angeguckt, ok, ich geb zu, ist
es vielleicht jetzt nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss, wenn man sich so die abschließende
Meinung über einen Tutorial Kurs bildet, aber das, was ich gesehen hab, hat mir, nee,
kein Bock, mir ist auch nur ansatzweise anzugucken, allein schon, ich bin auch kein XAML Fan,
kommt da auch noch dabei, du musst Qt nicht kaufen, es sei denn, ich glaub, du kannst
sogar glaube ich kommerzielle Produkte mit Qt machen, du darfst bloß irgendwie nicht,
darfst irgendwie nicht mitliefern oder irgendwie so ganz komisches Zeug, keine Ahnung, ich
hab die Qt Lizenz besonders nicht verstanden, das Problem ist, gar nicht Qt selbst, sondern
C++ und ja, ich weiß, man kann vieles in Qt mittlerweile reinfronten, technisch in ihrem
komischen Javascript Dialekt machen oder in Python, aber wenn man wirklich Custom Control
und sowas machen will, wahrscheinlich kommst du um C++ nicht rum, also, aber wir reden
ja gar nicht mal von Cross Platform, nur Microsoft selber, warum kriegt das Microsoft selber
auf Windows, wir reden jetzt nicht von Cross Platform, warum kriegt das Microsoft auf Windows,
auf ihrer eigenen Platform nicht hin, ein gescheites UI Framework zu machen, was mit
UI Framework meine ist, wo man solche Anwendungen hier drin machen kann, sowas hier, wo man
ganz normale Windows Anwendungen drin machen, gibt es nicht, es gibt Windows Forms, das
ist ur, ur, uralt, das ist für Quick and Dirty Sachen, die eigentlich keiner wirklich
benutzen will, das ist WPF, das ist eigentlich unsinnig zu lernen, weil es ist ein bisschen
aktueller als Windows Forms, aber trotzdem hoffnungslos veraltet und es gibt UWP, was
immer noch so viele Einschränkungen hat, dass es Kassau verwenden will, also Microsoft,
was ist los, ich mein, Microsoft selber, ja MVC ist ja quasi, geht quasi in die Richtung
von Windows Forms, es ist Windows API, raw Windows API halt in C++ gerappt und nicht
in Windows Forms gerappt, also macht ja hier auch keinen Unterschied, was ist los Microsoft,
wo gibt es da nix, guck mal, Microsoft selbst verwendet, passt mal auf, habe ich den Installer,
guck mal, Microsoft selbst, was meint ihr, meint ihr, ob das hier eine Windows Anwendung
ist, was meint ihr, was der Wishlist Studio Installer ist, was könnte das sein, meint
ihr, das ist eine Windows Anwendung, ok, ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich eine Windows Anwendung,
ich hätte jetzt gedacht, das ist elektronisch, ich glaube, das ist wirklich eine Windows
Anwendung, ok, Moment, Moment, das Fenster ist Windows, ob der Inhalt Windows ist, muss
man mal, muss man sich mal überlegen, Moment, wir checken, wir mussten mal kurz checken,
was das ist, deck, müssen wir mal kurz, müssen wir mal kurz überprüfen, set up, cute, nee,
Quicktime, Quicktime Java, nee, das ist ein Wein, da sieht man nix,.net Assemblies, ist
es.net, ah, es scheint.net zu sein, es ist eine WPF Anwendung, man spricht das cute aus,
cute, aber es ist natürlich auch, es ist eine WPF Anwendung, wie es aussieht, oder, MonkaS,
hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, seriously, es ist eine WPF Anwendung, ich dachte immer,
das ist elektronisch, ah gut, so WPF Anwendung, Microsoft bleibt ja selbst nichts anderes übrig
als in outdated, wahrscheinlich ist es irgendwas Browser-geraptes in WPF oder so, weil es sieht
ehrlich gesagt für WPF deutlich zu modern aus, zumindest Microsoft verwendet selbst
für vieles mittlerweile Elektron und für poplische Sachen wie Installer, morgen gibt
es eine Standardempfehlung, eine gute Standardempfehlung gibt es ja eigentlich bei fast nix, Original
Studio Code finde ich ok als Elektron Anwendung, weil es ist Cross-Platform und läuft überall
und soll überall gleich aussehen, aber warum muss man denn Windows-only Installer in Elektron
machen? Standardempfehlung gibt es immer, ist immer schwierig, weil du musst ja halt
überlegen, was weiß ich, wie viele Clients hast du, wo willst du das Ding platzieren,
hast du irgendwelche Wände, wie viele brauchst du, also das UniFi Zeug ist schon in Ordnung,
das kann man nehmen, ich hab, bin kein großer UniFi Fan, muss ich sagen, das liegt aber
an mehreren Sachen, mir fehlen Features, die ich gerne hätte und UniFi absolut keinen
Bock hat, die einzubauen, eigentlich ein größeres Feature, wo UniFi, also ich möchte WLAN-Passwörter
pro Geräte vergeben können, das können fast alle anderen Hersteller, sogar D-Link, nee
nicht D-Link, TP-Link kann es mittlerweile auch mit ihrem UniFi-Klon, aber UniFi selbst
hat absolut keine Böcke, das einzubauen, UniFi, wir gucken mal, vielleicht gibt es
ja neue Sachen auf Reddit, jetzt wo die Konkurrenz von TP-Link das gemacht hat, gucken wir mal
mal, hallo, ob die das auch mittlerweile haben, nö, nein, drei Jahre, fünf Jahre, die haben
keinen Bock, die wollen nicht bei Ubiquiti, also das ist ein Feature, was mir fehlt und
ansonsten, klar geht das, wo soll das denn, wo soll das gehen, ich rede nicht von WPA-Enterprise,
ich rede von WLAN-Passwort pro Gerät, für Geräte, die kein WPA-Enterprise können,
ja, also das fehlt mir und ich hatte bei dem einen AccessPoint ziemliche Verbindungsprobleme,
da weiß ich aber immer noch nicht genau, woran es gelegen hat, aber ansonsten ist das UniFi-Zeug
tatsächlich ganz in Ordnung, der Controller ist sicherlich Geschmackssache, ich mag die
Bedienung von dem Controller gar nicht, ich finde, die Sachen sind nicht so benannt, dass
man das versteht, was da steht, was sie damit meinen, dann ist es mir lieber, sie schreiben
irgendeinen Technikbegriff dran und was ich halt auch bei den UniFi-Zeug nicht mag, ist,
wenn du eine Änderung irgendwo durchführst, dann werden alle AccessPoints komplett neu
deployed und das dauert irgendwie zwei Minuten, bis alle AccessPoints durch sind, sich rebooted
und dann verbinden sich alle Geräte random wieder neu, also das könnte man sicherlich
schöner machen, aber an sich, wenn du einfach nur halbwegs funktionierendes WLAN-Zeug brauchst,
mit ein paar Bonus-Features kannst du das Zeug nehmen, ansonsten kannst du dir aber
auch, wenn du nix brauchst, wenn du einfach nur WLAN-Krempel brauchst und jetzt nicht
das Haus allzu groß ist, du kannst dir auch irgendeinen billigen AccessPoint von Amazon
dahinstellen, das funktioniert erstmal genauso gut, das UniFi-Zeug ist dann ganz praktisch
und es ist jetzt auch nicht, als wenn UniFi-AccessPoints irgendwie super krass höhere Bildqualität
oder sowas, als ein billiger andere Amazon AccessPoint, wo das UniFi-Zeug seine Vorteile
hat, ist, wenn du beispielsweise wirklich ein Haus hast mit Garten und Terrasse und Hof
und sowas und du möchtest beispielsweise, sagen wir mal, vier, fünf AccessPoints irgendwie
über das ganze Grundstück verteilt haben, dass du überall bis in den letzten Winkel,
vielleicht auch ein Auto AccessPoint und sowas, dass du überall bis in den letzten
Winkel WLAN hast und du möchtest die Zentral-Managen, dass du nicht jeden AccessPoint selbst managen
musst.
Dafür ist das ganz gut, plus vielleicht noch so ein paar Hilfen, die das Ding hat, dass
du beispielsweise scannen kannst, wo sind freie Channels, dass du das gut verteilen
kannst und so.
Für das Management ist das UniFi-Zeug gut, rein für irgendwie die super krasse Bildqualität
der AccessPoint musstest du jetzt nicht kaufen, weil die Dinger sind auch nicht wirklich
keine Ahnung, besser als der 0815 AccessPoint.
Es ist ein Draht drinnen als Antenne, wie bei jedem anderen AccessPoint.
Kann man sich kaufen, ist okay, aber es ist so ein Wunder, muss man sich davon jetzt
nicht erwarten.
Also mal angenommen, du hast aktuell eine Fritzbox stehen in deiner Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung
und dann musst du dir nicht erwarten, dass du jetzt irgendwie mit einem UniFi AccessPoint
auf einmal krass viel besser bist.
Einziger Unterschied ist, theoretisch, wenn du jetzt halt ein UniFi 6 Produkt nimmst und
deine Fritzbox kann halt kein AX WLAN oder Wi-Fi 6 oder Wi-Fi 5, aber selbst dann muss
man ehrlich sagen, das brauchst du meistens ja gar nicht.
Selbst AC, also der vorletzte Standard, ist immer noch schnell genug für die paar Geräte,
die man in so einer Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung hat und das wirst du nicht merken.
Das merkst du höchstens, wenn du einen Speedtest machst und dich direkt neben den AccessPoint
stellst.
Also ansonsten, das kann man machen, das ist sicherlich keine schlechte Entscheidung,
aber nur wenn man halt wirklich da Verbesserung durchhält, einfach mal ein UniFi Zeug hinstellen
nur, weil man dann denkt, es wird viel besser, hat eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Ich werde mein UniFi Zeug wahrscheinlich wieder abschaffen.
Ja, ein Gigabit, wer kriegt schon ein Gigabit über WLAN?
Du kannst theoretisch glaube ich mit Wi-Fi 6, kannst du, wenn du direkt neben den AccessPoint
stehst mit sehr viel Glück und du Geräte hast mit mehreren Antennen und was auch immer,
kannst du theoretisch über WLAN, aber das ist unrealistisch, gehst ein paar Meter weg,
ist das Ding schon wieder ein ganz normaler Gefild.
Das ist Schwachsinn, wo das tatsächlich alles seine Vorteile hat, ist durch neuere Sachen
wie, dass du jetzt, wie heißt das, Beamforming-Gedöns hast, mittlerweile standardmäßig in
Wi-Fi 6 und dass du durch die höhere Bandbreite natürlich dann auch potentiell mehr Clients
bedienen kannst, wobei es halt auch daheim so ist, du bist im Leben nicht daheim in einem
Limit von so einem AccessPoint.
Was haben denn die Leute, ich meine bei mir ist es schon brutalst übertrieben, ich habe
aktuell glaube ich, wir haben letztens nachgeguckt, irgendwie 85 Geräte oder so stehen in meinem
Router drin, im DHCP, gut, von diesen 85 Geräten sind natürlich bei weitem nicht alles WLAN-Geräte,
lass es mal 30 oder lass mal die Hälfte, lass mal die Hälfte WLAN sein und das ist
alles dann aber zusammen, Tablets, Kameras, IoT-Geräte, WLAN-Steckdosen, WLAN-Lampen,
alles, ja, lass es mal 40 Dinger sein und ich behaupte einfach mal und das ist im ganzen
Haus, also Haus, Stall, Garten, Terrasse, Hof, Garage, Garten, Gartenhäus, alles, alles
zusammen, ja, alles zusammen und da behaupte ich mal bin ich mit 40 vielleicht 45 WLAN-Geräten
wahrscheinlich schon relativ hoch, was haben denn die meisten Leute daheim im WLAN?
Die haben vielleicht noch ein Laptop, 1, 2 Tablets, 1, 2 Smartphones, eventuell noch
ein paar, wenn sie modern sind, ein paar Sensoren oder so oder irgendein, was weiß ich, eine
schaltbare Steckdose, die meisten Leute, wenn die 15 Dinger im WLAN daheim haben, dann
ist da schon viel und das macht die, der billigste, der billigste, was ist denn so, der billigste
Netzwerkhersteller, keine Ahnung, der billigste TP-Link von Amazon macht die das, ja, so,
hat jemand einen für, ich hab keine Ahnung, die TP-Link, da hatten wir es letztens von,
also wenn du ein bisschen advancedere Features brauchst, dieser TP-Link Unify-Klon ist, zumindest
ich hab ihn selbst nicht getestet, ja, ist von den Features her und dem, was ich gesehen
hab bisher, echt nicht schlecht und die Axis Points sind auch nicht so teuer, also aktuell
rein vom Feature Set her, würde ich persönlich, wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste zwischen
Unify und dem TP-Link, ich würde mich wahrscheinlich aktuell zwischen für TP-Link entscheiden,
das liegt aber hauptsächlich an den Features und am Preis, die Kombination ist einfach
ziemlich gut, aber kein Unify, ist das deine Website, wusste ich gar nicht, hab ich gerade
gefunden über Google, ja, also ich würde eher zu dieser Sache tendieren, als zu Unify aktuell,
wobei ich halt auch aktuell nicht glücklich bin mit Unify, das muss man halt sehen, wenn
ich sowas erzähle, ja, also ich hab das Unify Zeug seit 2014 oder 2015, oder wann auch immer,
ich den ersten Axis Pointer gekauft hab, ausprobiert, das wurde zwar mit den Jahren ein bisschen
besser, das Unify Zeug läuft jetzt nicht mehr komplett amok, wenn du automatisches Channel
rausfinden einstellst, das war ja früher komplett useless, aber mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr
ganz so schlimm, aber ja, immer wenn ich sowas erzähle, ich bin auch nicht so glücklich
mit dem Unify Zeug, ja, also ich kenn übrigens noch einen, weil ich gerade im Chat sehe,
der nicht glücklich mit Unify ist, zumindest laut dem Video, und ich hab das TP Link Zeug
nicht ausprobiert, aber rein von den Features her, was ich bisher gesehen hab, ist das relativ
ähnlich und es ist ein Ticken günstiger und es hat ein Feature, was ich halt unbedingt
haben will für IoT-Geräte, dass du, aber erst seit der Firmware von Ende März, dass
du IoT-Geräten eigene Passwörter geben kannst.
Was hältst du von Windows 11 besser als Windows 10?
Tja, keine Ahnung, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, das was ich gesehen hab, hat mich abgeschreckt,
das Schlimmste unter Windows 11 für mich ist diese komische, ich weiß, das sind zwar
Kleinigkeiten, aber letztendlich ist das was abfuckt, weil es jeden Tag verwendest,
ist das was mich direkt genervt hat bei Windows 11, ist diese neue Startleiste, wo du Tabs
immer nur gruppiert haben kannst und nicht auseinander, in der Windows 11 Startleiste
hätte ich Chrome jetzt nicht zwei Fenster zum Durchklicken, sondern Chrome zusammen,
sowas bescheuertes.
Chat, wir gucken uns gleich Sachen an, ich muss erstmal hier durch mich nochmal schnell
durchkämpfen.
Äh, wie soll das funktionieren?
Die SSID ist doch die gleiche.
Die SSID, also, außerdem bräuchtest du dann 50 SSIDs oder sowas, also was ich meine ist,
ich hab 50 WLAN Steckdosen, ich sag jetzt mal, ich hab keine 50 WLAN Steckdosen, ja,
ich sag nur mal theoretisch, theoretischer Fall, ich hab 50 WLAN Steckdosen und jede
WLAN Steckdose soll ein eigenes WLAN Passwort bekommen, das geht mit UniFi nicht.
Es gibt Feature-Requests, die sind Jahre alt und die unterstützen sowas nicht.
Jeder andere Hersteller, sogar TP-Link, seit der Firmware vom März kann das, okay, jeder
ist übertrieben, der 5€ Amazon Access Point kann das nicht, aber Aruba kann das, Ruggus
kann das, TP-Link kann das, Mikrotik, sogar die günstigen Mikrotiks können das, also
nur UniFi hat da keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch, Aruba nur mit ClearPass, ja, deswegen hab ich mir auch
nie Gedanken zugemacht, das zu kaufen, weil das viel zu teuer ist und Paints Champ, aber
von der Idee her, die anderen können das, UniFi kann das nicht und mag das auch nicht
und das ist halt, wenn man viele IoT-Geräte hat oder viele WLAN-Geräte, praktisch, weil,
wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel eine, bleiben wir bei der WLAN Steckdose, ihr habt eine
WLAN Steckdose, danke für den Subgift, ach, ein anonymer Gifter, ja, danke schön anonymer
Gifter, bleiben wir mal bei der WLAN Steckdose, wenn die mal kaputt geht und ich schmeiß
sie weg, dann ist ja in der WLAN Steckdose nach wie vor ein Mikrocontroller drin mit
meinem WLAN Passwort, das schmeiß ich weg, natürlich, wenn man es mal realistisch sieht,
wie hoch ist die Chance, dass irgendjemand an meinen Müll geht, die WLAN Steckdose nimmt,
den Controller auslötet und mein WLAN Passwort ausliest, wahrscheinlich verschwindend gering,
so gering, dass man sich wahrscheinlich nicht mal Gedanken darüber machen muss, aber, warum
sollte man es überhaupt, wie soll ich sagen, warum sollte man überhaupt so ein Verfahren
verwenden, wenn es dann theoretisch quasi möglich ist oder beispielsweise du verkaufst ein altes
Tablet und hast es nicht resettet oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas, ja, es ist praktisch, wenn
man einzelne Passwörter pro Gerät vergeben kann, weil dann kannst du das Passwort einfach
beziehungsweise in deinem Interface, löschst du einfach das Gerät und kannst das Ding
wegschmeißen und das kann zwar jemand das Passwort auslesen, aber kommt mit diesem Passwort
nicht mehr in deinen WLAN rein und das ist halt nice und das kann Unify nicht.
Du kannst, was du bei Unify machen kannst und das ist wahrscheinlich das, was du meinst,
du kannst bei Unify theoretisch mehrere SSIDs anlegen mit unterschiedlichen Passwörtern,
aber dann müsstest du am Endeffekt 50 SSIDs, ich glaube, das unterstützt der Controller
gar nicht, dann müsstest du 50 SSIDs anlegen und ich glaube, du kannst maximal nur 4 SSIDs
pro Access Point drauf machen, also 50 SSIDs ist vielleicht auch was Traffic und sowas
und so WLAN, was soll denn WLAN Verschmutzung angeht, nicht die beste Variante.
Ja, das reicht ja auch dicke, ganz ehrlich, AX, warte mal, ist AX, Moment, 802.11 AX,
das ist das Wi-Fi 6, ja, WLAN Standards, Alter, ja, das ist das neue, das kann zwar theoretisch
bis zu 1,4G oder irgendwie sowas, Max Speed, weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, ja, mit 4 Antennen,
5 Gigabit, alles klar, alles klar, realistisch betrachtet, ernsthaft Leute, realistisch betrachtet,
wenn du nicht quasi im optimalen Winkel im Access Point liegst und dein Handy aufmachst
für einen Speedtest, wirst du nicht mal ansatzweise auch nur im Entferntesten auf solche Werte
kommen, deswegen reicht sogar 1 Gigabit Anschluss locker und das Gute ist ja auch dadurch,
dass die theoretisch mehr können, reduziert, dass die Zeit, die einzelne Clients zum Übertragen
brauchen, was potenziell auch wieder der Sache zugute kommt, dass du mehr Clients damit abkannst,
aber du gerätst daheim eh nie, tschüss, machs gut, du gerätst daheim eh so gut wie
nie an die Leistungsgrenze eines Access Points, sondern eher an die Reichweitenbegrenzung,
wenn du ein großes Grundstück hast, ja, ihr hättet die Fritzbox auch ordentlich ausrichten
können wahrscheinlich, wie gesagt, wenn man solche Anwendungsfälle hat, lohnt sich das
schon, aber in der kleinen Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung nicht, also wenn man in der kleinen Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung
Probleme mit der Fritzbox hat, dann sind die wahrscheinlich auch nicht gelöst durch ein
Unified Access Point. Ja, ich hab's bei mir ähnlich, also ich hab' die Fritzbox, also
ich hab' hier, Moment, Moment, mein Paint, ich hab' doch hier ein Bild von meinem Netzwerk,
kein Quade, huge, massive Fiveheader, ups, falsches, falsches, falsches E-Mode, also
ich hab' immer noch diese hässliche Unity Media Connectbox, Internetanschluss, hier
könnte ich zwar ein eigenes Modem hinhauen, aber warum? Hier ist die Fritzbox, die ist
nur für VoIP und Deck-Telefone da, weil das will man, VoIP und Deck will man nicht selbst
machen, dann hab' ich als eigentlichen Hauptrouter von Mikrotik eine Kiste, dort ist auch alles
mögliche eingestellt von WLAN-Config, DHCP, NTP, Firewall-Regeln, Zeugs, ja, so, dann
da drunter hab' ich einen 10 Gigabit-Switch mit 12 SFP-Plus und 4 AJ45-Kupfer-Ports, irgendwo
hier hängt dann auch mal ein Desktop dran über ein paar Umwege, internes Netzwerk,
und dann hab' ich noch drei, drei Access Points, okay, mittlerweile sind's vier, Access Points
dran über PoE für WLAN-Sachen, einer im Keller, einer im Endgeschoss, einer im ersten
Stock und einer für die Terrasse und den Garten draußen, aber ganz ehrlich, ich bin
mit dem UniFi zeuglich nicht glücklich, und mit zwei SSIDs, einmal ein WLAN für die
normalen Geräte und einmal ein IoT-WLAN, und es wäre halt cool, hätte dieses IoT-WLAN
die Möglichkeit, Custom Password dazu zu setzen, was UniFi nicht mag. Ja, so sieht das bei
mir aus. Du musst mal gucken, ob's reicht, guck mal, ob's reicht, je nachdem, wie dick
das ist, und was sonst noch drumherum ist, reicht das trotzdem, probier's einfach aus,
stell dich auf die andere Seite der Wohnung, mach einen Speedtest, wenn das funktioniert,
ordentlich, mit ordentlicher Bandbreite und ohne viel Geschwanke, ist eigentlich alles
in Ordnung. Also ich würd mir keine WLAN-Geräte auf gut Glück kaufen, sondern einfach mal
ausprobieren, ob das überhaupt notwendig ist. MikroTik doch, haben die auch, aber nicht
so schön von der Handhabung her, und ich hab' keine MikroTik Access Points, die haben
mich bis jetzt auch nicht überzeugt. Was wir steigen bei uns im Hotel, höchstwahrscheinlich
von Office 2015, Office 365, ja wir haben auch auf der Arbeit Office 365, und ich mach
immer einen riesen Bogen drumherum, ich würde aber auch einen riesen Bogen um Office 2019
machen, ist nicht so, dass ich damit lieber arbeiten würde, aber ihr kennt mich ja, ihr
wisst, dass ich Office Sweeten, beziehungsweise Office Pakete für komplette Zeitverschwendung
und überflüssig halte. Das einzige Programm, was eine Daseinsberechtigung hat, aus, egal
ob es LibreOffice ist oder Office oder sonst was, ist Excel oder die Tabellenkalkulation
und auch nur, weil das quasi die Datenbank für die Hausfrau oder den Hausmann ist. Das
braucht kein Mensch. Textverarbeitung ist eh das aller sinnloseste überhaupt. Ich soll
das mal erforschen, schauen, wie wir das angehen können, falls der Chef das Go gibt. Wisst
ihr das Problem, wenn ich testweise eine Lizenz kaufe? Ich hab' keinen Plastenschimmer, damit
kenne ich mich nicht aus. Vielleicht der Chat, vielleicht Chat, wenn ihr das wisst, dann
schreibt es dem Dark Zone mal, ich hab' keine Ahnung, also von Microsoft Zeug und gerade
der Exchange, da bin ich komplett planlos. Ja das ist ja gut, wenn man Probleme hat, spricht
ja auch nichts dagegen, das zu upgraden, aber einfach nur auf gut Glück, weil es irgendein
Typ auf Twitch oder YouTube gesagt hat, würde ich das nicht machen. Ich finde es so, also
die Dinger sind jetzt nicht per se schlecht, aber ich hab' da halt immer so Kleinigkeiten
bei dem Unified Zeug dabei, was mir nicht gefällt und ja. Ich hab' ein AC Lite im Keller,
weil der im Edgeschoss nicht gereicht hat. Das ist aber auch ein richtig dicker Keller.
Also ihr müsst wissen, das Haus ist so alt, wo ich hier wurde, das hat nicht der Opa gebaut,
das hat glaube ich der Opa vom Opa gebaut oder so, mein Opa ist ja dann irgendwann
nach Südafrika abgehauen und hat die Frau hier sitzen lassen und alles, das haben aber
zu dieser Zeit viele gemacht, heck wait, also man könnte quasi sagen, ich bin zu einem
Viertel Afrikaner, zu null, zumindest die haben im ersten und zweiten Weltkrieg, haben
die hier im Keller gesessen, weil sie Angst vor Bomben hatten und also der Keller ist
wirklich relativ massiv. So und das hat aus einem Edgeschoss, der Access Point, hat gereicht
bis direkt unten drunter, aber nicht mehr auf die andere Seite vom Keller, deswegen hab'
ich noch ein AC Lite im Keller gehängt. Was glücklicherweise gut funktioniert hat, weil
ich ein Netzwerkkabel von mir hier im Serverraum runter in den Keller hab', da musste ich zwar
die Telekom Leitung kappen, die ich eh nicht mehr verwende, weil ich keinen Telekom Anschluss
hab', weil ich hab' acht Adern gebraucht und zwei, also es waren sechs Adern frei und
zwei Adern in dem Kabel waren verwendet für den Telekom Anschluss, den ich nicht mehr
verwende, deswegen hab' ich das einfach abgezwackt, oben ein Stecker drauf gekrimmt, nee stimmt
nicht, ich hab' keinen Stecker drauf gekrimmt, ich hab' einen Stecker drauf keystoned in
so eine Dose und unten im Keller auch und hab' dann per POE den Access Point hingehängt.
Ja, ich find' das doof, dass so viel auch diese Meraki Cisco Dinger, die ja vom Ansatz
ja auch gar nicht so schlecht sind, ich hasse das mit reiner Cloud-Verwaltung, was soll
das, gibt es jetzt mal ernsthaft, ich glaube nämlich, dass es das gibt, aber ich kann's
nicht nachvollziehen, gibt es wirklich Unternehmen, ich mein' das richtet sich ja nicht an Hobby-Anwender,
das ist ja schon für, ich nenne mal Profis, das Zeug ist ja auch teuer als Fuck, gibt
es wirklich Unternehmen, die ihre WLAN-Infrastruktur über die Cloud verwalten, also sprich, du
kannst in deinem WLAN-Lokal nichts mehr ändern, wenn mal der Cloud-Zugang nicht funktioniert?
Ich mein' warum, warum sollte ich sowas machen?
Das verstehe ich nicht, es scheint es zu geben, weil sonst gibt es die Hersteller nicht mehr.
Ihr habt eine Hydraulikpresse, du solltest unbedingt mal einen YouTube-Channel erstellen.
Hydraulikpressen-Channel gehen auf YouTube durch die Decke, braucht es, braucht irgendwie
einen coolen Namen, Extreme Hydraulikpress oder sowas, und dann zerpresst du, äh, zerpresst,
zerpresst, was ist denn die Vergangenheit von zerpressen?
Dann zerpressst du, was zerpristest du?
Ich weiß nicht, also dann hast du zumindest zerpresst, ähm, mit einer Kamera dabei und
zerpresst du alles Mögliche und dann ist gut.
Dann machst du Videos und hast zwei Millionen Abos.
USB-Standards, ja da hab ich mich auch schon öfters drüber aufgeregt.
Meine IP-Tabelle ist meine DHCP Server Leases, meine DHCP Server Leases ist meine IP-Tabelle,
das reicht.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich erstaunlich gut.
Ähm, nein hab ich nicht, ich hab nur Fotos, ich könnte mir sowas erstellen, weil ich
hab Fotos noch von der Renovierung, ich weiß wo Kabel liegen, aber das hab ich kein Bock
drauf.
Bisschen laut auf einmal.
Gibt es eigentlich Access Point, die SSH Keys unterstützen als Login praktisch?
Äh, ich würd mal sagen, die meisten Access Point, die SSH Login unterstützen prinzipiell
unterstützen auch SSH Keys, warum nicht?
Ich hab's ehrlich gesagt noch nicht ausprobiert, also die UniFi Dinger, bin ich mir nicht
sicher, ob man SSH Keys hinterlegen kann für Login, das Login dort per SSH ist ja eh nur
gedacht für, wenn die Autodiscovery mal wieder nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was empfiehlst du denn, äh, einen Texteditor mit Markdown?
Wenn du natürlich jetzt, sag mal mal so, diese Kombination brauchst aus Textverarbeitung,
plus dass du irgendwie auch, ähm, mal ne Adresse schön pixelgenau oben links anordnen kannst
sowas, dann kann man schon ne Textverarbeitung verwenden, Textverarbeitung ist halt so die
gute Mischung aus Texteditor und Textsatz, nennen wir es mal, für D0A15 Anwender, aber
die Sache ist halt die, genau, es gibt immer bessere Variante für die jeweils einzelnen
Fälle, aber in Kombination ist so eine Textverarbeitung schon okay, ich benutze das seit Jahren nicht
mehr, ich benutze den Texteditor mit Markdown und fertig.
Hat den Vorteil, ich kann es auch einfach als HTML rendern.
Oder als PDF.
Ich mach sogar Präsentationen mittlerweile nur noch als Markdown mit als in PDF Format.
Einzig, wo ich das nicht mach, ist manchmal auf der Arbeit, wenn irgendjemand wieder ganz
energisch dahinter her ist, dass man die Unternehmens-, wie soll ich sagen, wie heißt das so, die
Präsentationsvorlage für die Corporate Identity verwendet.
Ja, dann mach ich im Browser irgendein Word-, irgendein Powerpoint-Ding.
Der Chat weiß Bescheid, guck hier, wieder richtig Fiveheader.
Ja, Facebook macht vieles komische Zeug.
Beides, wir haben, ursprünglich mal hatten wir Offline oder On-Prem, wie die coolen Leute
sagen, aber einfach Lokal, ich nenne das Lokal, weil ich hasse diese Bezeichnung On-Prem,
das ist so für die coolen Leute, die zeigen wollen, wie krass Cloud-Native sie sind, für
die es lokal betreiben ist, das geht nicht, das darf man nicht, On-Prem muss das sein,
also wir hatten früher Jira und Confluence lokal installiert, also lief auch bei uns
im Rechenzentrum und mittlerweile sind wir umgestiegen auf die Cloud-Lösung von Atlassian,
weil die Offline-Installation bzw. die Lokal-Installation werden ja auch nicht mehr so lange supportet,
wir haben aber noch ein paar Überbleibsel, die sind noch lokal, also ich glaube Jira
ist schon komplett online, aber Confluence haben wir glaube ich online und noch irgendwie
eine alte Instanz Offline, kein Schimmer, was die da treiben, zumindest muss ich sagen,
die Atlassian Cloud ist ziemlicher Rotz, nicht nur was die Performance angeht, die deutlich
hinter dem zurück bleibt, was die lokale Installation hat, ich meine die lokale Installation war
schon nicht schnell, aber die Cloud-Installation ist normal, dass du teilweise mittags den
Tab aufmachst und 15 Sekunden brauchst bis die Seite geladet ist, also das ist wirklich
ganz abartig und dazu kommt, ich weiß nicht inwieweit ihr das mitbekommen habt, das hat
große Kreise gezogen, Atlassian hatte auch letztens einfach mal glaube ich 3 Wochen Cloud-Ausfall,
also für alle die es nicht mitbekommen haben, für ja, für ungefähr 3 Wochen, also für
400, wir müssen mal den heißen Artikel lesen, ich glaube das ist besser, guck mal, also
die haben quasi für, weiß ich nicht ob die Anzahl der Kunden, also für 400 Kunden ging
das mehrere Wochen der Ausfall, das musst du dir mal vorstellen, stelle dir mal vor,
du hast da Sachen drin und du brauchst das, das kannst du, ich will vielleicht jetzt nicht
sagen das vernichtet Unternehmen, das ist vielleicht bisschen so hochgegriffen, aber
danach ist doch von denen, wobei ganz ehrlich, ich wollte gerade sagen, danach ist doch,
also von diesen Leuten, die hier 4 Wochen oder so vom Ausfall betroffen waren, wollte
ich gerade sagen, danach ist doch keiner mehr bei Atlassian in der Cloud, aber man unterschätzt
oder ich habe gerade den Business-Dongs-Entscheidermensch unterschätzt, der wahrscheinlich auch danach
entscheidet, ja Atlassian hat doch jetzt aus ihren Fehlern gelernt, wir bleiben in der
Atlassian Cloud, weil wir haben jetzt auch vom Atlassian Sales Team ein super Angebot
bekommen, dass wir quasi die Sache jetzt für ein Jahr umsonst betreiben können, dann
scheiß doch drauf, dass es 3 Wochen kaputt war, aber gleichzeitig möchte er von seinen
Leuten, dass sie ein Backup haben, dass wenn es wieder ausfällt, das wäre so eine typische
Manager-Entscheidung, so nach dem Motto, ja dann bleiben wir doch in der Atlassian Cloud,
aber Leute sorgt mal dafür, dass es auch ohne Atlassian Cloud geht, ja Moment, aber du
hast doch entschieden, dass wir die Atlassian Cloud verwenden, wenn wir dafür sorgen sollen,
dass es auch offline geht, dann brauchen wir die Atlassian Cloud nicht dafür, ja technische
Implementierung interessiert mich jetzt nicht, aber ich habe das jetzt entschieden und das
machen wir jetzt so, also mit Realität muss das ja nicht viel zu tun haben, Teams ist nicht
übel, ganz im Ernst, ich fluche zwar auch öfters über Teams rum, vor allem wenn mich
jemand im Stream gebated, das angeblich Teams gebimmelt hätte, aber es ist in Ordnung und
Microsoft baute auch tatsächlich sinnvolle Features ein, zum Beispiel diese automatische
AI Hintergrundausblendung und sowas finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Frage, sollte zuhause Installation Fritzbox, Switch, Access Point machen oder Access Point
direkt an die Fritzbox gehen, ganz ehrlich, weißt du was ich machen würde, ich würde
einfach, wenn du eh eine Fritzbox kaufst, ich würde einfach mal probieren, ob ich alleine
mit der Fritzbox auskomme, weil die Fritzbox ist ein Switch, die Fritzbox ist ein Access
Point, ein Modem, eine Deckbasis Station, billig nass und sonst was, also Fritzbox ist
ein gutes Multifunktionsgerät, ich würde einfach mal ausprobieren, ob ich damit klarkomme,
wenn ich einfach nur die Fritzbox verwende, wenn du Features hast, die die Fritzbox nicht
kann, wenn du Qualitätsprobleme hast, WLAN, sonst was, dann kann man sich das immer noch
überlegen, aber ansonsten würde ich einfach, wenn ich eh eine Fritzbox kaufe, erstmal ausprobieren,
ob ich mit der Fritzbox alleine klarkomme.
Und ja natürlich gibt es einen Unterschied, je nachdem was du für Features haben willst,
wenn du beispielsweise WLAN Support willst, ist die Fritzbox nicht brauchbar, wenn du
ordentliche Firewallregeln machen willst, die Fritzbox auch nicht brauchbar, möchtest
du gar irgendwie sowas internes wie irgendwelche Routingprotokolle machen, was man eigentlich
daheim nicht macht, aber nur für den Fall der Fälle, kannst du die Fritzbox auch vergessen,
wenn du ehm, irgendwelche WLAN Spezialitäten brauchst, die die Fritzbox nicht kann, kannst
du die Fritzbox auch vergessen, wenn du mehr Ports brauchst als die Fritzbox hat, brauchst
noch ein extra Switch, ja also die Fritzbox kann das prinzipiell alles, aber wenn du halt
mehr brauchst oder andere Dinge als die Fritzbox kann, brauchst du extra Geräte, aber die
meisten Leute kommen in der Fritzbox ganz gut klar, deswegen würde ich es auch erstmal
so probieren, wie gesagt, ich würde mich da gar nicht so sehr darauf einlassen, es sagen
so viele Leute, hier sei es Twitch, Youtube, sonst wie, so nach dem Motto, ah ja Fritzbox
hier, kauft ihr noch das dazu, macht ihr jenes, alles Müll, ich lässt da auch ganz gerne
über die Fritzbox, so nach dem Motto AVM, die rote Pest aus Berlin oder sowas, das ist
aber gar nicht so schlecht, die Fritzbox ist ein wirklich sinniges, gutes Multifunktionsgerät,
die ist jetzt kein herausragender Router, die mag auch keine, also von Features her, kein
herausragender Switch und kein herausragender Access Point sein, aber die Kombination und
gerade von solchen Sachen, die du für daheim brauchst, wie beispielsweise, wenn du noch
Schnullos Telefone hast und sowas, oder wenn du Voice over IP machen willst, sowas, das
ist halt gut, schön, Webinterface, Technik, Fritzbox integriert, 90% von dem, was man machen
möchte als Heimanwender, oder sag mal so 99%, was die meisten machen wollen, ist in der
Fritzbox ohne Probleme möglich, man kann das Ding sogar als billig nass verwenden, ist okay
und erst wenn du mehr machen willst und sagst, ja das brauch ich und das will ich unbedingt
haben, dann würde ich mir überlegen, was anderes zu machen, was zum Teufel soll eine
On-Prem Cloud sein, ist das quasi irgendeine Appliance, wo Cloud drauf steht, die bei einem
Rechenzentrum läuft oder, Leute dazu gibt es eine mega leiste Story, die Story muss ich
mal in einem Video erzählen, die Story muss ich, vielleicht mach ich das heute, die muss
ich erzählen und zwar nur mal so ganz kurz, weil On-Prem und Cloud, wir haben, bevor wir
auf der Arbeit Outlook hatten und Exchange, hatten wir Lotus Notes und Lotus Notes hatten
wir sowohl für intern als auch mit irgendeinem komischen, wie nennt sich das denn, Smartphone
Connector für den Außendienst, der Außendienst wusste zwar nicht, dass es Notes ist, aber
die haben Notes, war das Traveler, ich hab keine Ahnung, nee, nee, irgendein Connector,
da konntest du einfach glaube ich dann SMTP oder sowas und ein Map drüber machen, ist
auch egal, zumindest der Außendienst wusste nicht, dass es Notes im Becken ist, zumindest
ein Problem war, dass Notes im Kern ja eine riesen Datenbank ist, das heißt sowas wie
Archivierung und sowas sollte eigentlich ganz cool sein, aber unsere Notes hat Probleme
gemacht, deswegen haben sie sich damals irgendeinen Consulting Laden geholt, haben gesagt, macht
uns mal für unser Mailzeug eine ordentliche E-Mail Archivierung, auch für 10 Jahre oder
so, ich glaube man ist 10 Jahre verpflichtet diesen Krempel aufzuheben und es muss auch
recht sicher sein, insofern, dass wenn die Polizei anfragt, dass man auch E-Mails raussuchen
kann und dass man im Zweifelsfall auch E-Mails wieder herstellen kann, wenn im Außendienst
einer aus Versehen was gelöscht hat und sowas, zumindest haben sie irgendein Consulting Ding,
irgendeine Consulting Klitsche beauftragt, wahrscheinlich keine Klitsche, wahrscheinlich
was relativ großes, ich mein, wir haben Millionen für sowas und wir sind mitten in Frankfurt,
da gibt es bestimmt auch viele, zumindest dieser Consulting Laden wurde beauftragt,
macht mal E-Mail Archivierung für uns und wisst ihr was die gemacht haben, das ist kein
Witz, ich finde es immer noch Wahnsinn, irgendwann war ein Server in der Post, das war denen
ihre E-Mail Archivierungs Appliance, das war ein Tower-Gehäuse, noch nicht mal ein Rack,
noch nicht mal eine Rack-Bauweise, ein Tower-Gehäuse, irgendeine, ich glaube irgendeine Dell-Kiste
war das, irgendeine Dell Tower-Gehäuse und jetzt kommt der Hit, jetzt kommt der absolute
Hit, wir haben das Ding geschnappt, ins Rechenzentrum gebracht und haben uns schon gedacht, irgendwie
rumpelt dieses Gehäuse, du darfst ja nichts machen da dran, du darfst das nicht mal öffnen
bei solchen Appliance-Dingern und das war übrigens nur ein Testaufbau, also das war,
was sie uns geschickt haben, war quasi ein Prototyp, so könnte man das machen mit der
E-Mail Archivierung und wir sollten dann quasi bei uns das irgendwie umleiten darauf, dass
immer gespiegelt wird und was auch immer und wir haben uns aber schon bei dem Rechenzentrum
hochgetragen, irgendwie wackelt und scheppert dieses Gehäuse so, na gut, ne da lag ja nur
ein Prototyp drin, das war ja irgendeine Dell Workstation, kann schon sein, so ein Tower-Gehäuse,
so und da haben wir es halt in irgendeinen Rack reingestellt, was leer war, weil wo sollst
du es sonst hinstellen und dann haben die dann auch ihre E-Mail Archivierung gemacht
und so, ich weiß nur, dass die Leute nicht so super zufrieden damit waren und das Ding
hat auch Probleme gemacht wie Sau und irgendwann haben wir uns gedacht, Leute, warum raschelt
das, warum hat das geraschelt und haben gesagt, wir gucken doch, wir gucken uns das jetzt
doch mal an und da war allen Ernstes eine Festplatte lose drin, da ist eine Festplatte
hin und her gerutscht in dem Gehäuse, also sie haben uns irgendwie ihre super geile Appliance
geschickt für Archivierung mit losen Festplatten drin, also und dafür haben wir wahrscheinlich
hunderttausende bezahlt oder so, absoluter Wahnsinn, Business Enterprise Stonks Zeug,
Enterprise Business agiles Hard Drive, ja, die haben danach den Auftrag auch nicht gekriegt,
ja, da bekommt Hotspot direkt wieder richtig neue Bedeutung, muss demnächst Chira benutzen,
ist das menschenfreundlich, das geht schon, das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie sehr
eure Admins das verunstalten, es gibt für Chira tausende Plugins, ja, wo man den Editor
umstellen kann, wo man irgendwelche Workflows enforceen kann, also wo man aus einem einfachen
Ticketsystem quasi versucht irgendein super krasses Workflow Tool mit Datenbank zu machen,
dann ist es beschissen, das probiert man bei uns nämlich, wenn man das einfach nur als
Ticketsystem verwendet, ist Chira finde ich echt okay, wozu brauchen wir das, das weiß
ich jetzt nicht auf was ich das bezieht, Chira das ist ganz normales Ticketsystem, das ist
wenn du super agiles sein willst, da brauchst du ein Ticketsystem, ja Confluence ist wieder
das eine, Confluence mag ich persönlich auch nicht, wobei wir hatten mal, als ich noch
beim alten Arbeitgeber war, hatten wir ein Dokumentationssystem, das muss ich euch mal
zeigen, das war das mit Abstand beschissenste Knowledge Management, was ich je gesehen habe,
ihr seht ja ich glaube, Moment, wie ist das, ich glaube so, Sabio Knowledge Management,
die einfachste Knowledge Management, ich zeige euch mal Bilder davon, ne ne so, Moment, so
modern sah das noch nicht aus, das ist die neuere Version davon, unsere Version sah
deutlich antiker aus, so modern sah das nicht aus, das war massivster Paintschamp Leute,
ich hab noch nie sowas schreckliches gesehen, als Wikki quasi, das war so schlimm, ja die
haben nur die neuen Screenshots, nicht den Krempel von früher, grün war das auf jeden
Fall, das weiß ich, so, das hatten wir vorher und das war so unglaublicher Rotz, dass ich
eigentlich ganz froh war, als wir Confluence bekommen haben, achja, um da noch eins obendrauf
zu setzen, wobei ich glaube, das bringe ich jetzt durcheinander, ich glaube das, ja doch,
das bringe ich durcheinander, aber noch mal ein, ja das war was anderes, ey Leute, B-Ratius,
lasst es bleiben, sofern das noch, und das sag ich mal Disclaimer, ja natürlich keine
Beratung oder so, will ich das nicht verklagen am Ende, wenn das noch so ist wie damals,
das ist schon bestimmt 5, 6 Jahre oder so her, und das war auch nicht diese Version,
die man da gesehen hat, vielleicht ist das gar nicht mehr so schlecht, aber das was wir
damals hatten war ganz, ganz abartiger Abfakt, zumindest noch eine Sache jetzt, bevor wir
das Video dann gucken, wir haben ein anderes System für, wie nennt man das, Asset Management
heißt das glaube ich, wo man Hardware und Software Lizenzen und so drinnen pflegt und
Hardware erfasst, ich glaube Asset Management nennt man das so, insgesamt, und dieses Ding,
das ist so alt gewesen, als wir das eingeführt haben, das ist noch nicht so lange her, 4
Jahre oder so, 3 Jahre, 3, 4 Jahre, vor Corona, aber nicht so lange vor Corona, wurde das
eingeführt und die hatten damals noch als einziges, Leute ratet mal, das Web Frontend,
das war eine Web Anwendung, in was war das Web Frontend programmiert, 2018, Web Frontend,
Java Applets, ah geht in die richtige Richtung, Ruby, nee Frontend, ich sag's euch, Flash,
es war noch Flash im Jahr 2018, das einzige Frontend, was es gab, war Flash in 2018, Flash,
du brauchst ein Legacy Browser mit Legacy Plugin, dass du das überhaupt verwenden kannst,
eine neue Software, die du gekauft hast, Flash, so und mittlerweile, mittlerweile haben sie
ein HTML Web Interface, immerhin, aber sie haben es bis heute nicht gepatcht, das ist
wirklich heftig, wenn man sich überlegt, der gleiche Hersteller hat bis heute Log4j nicht
gepatcht, also ich meine, es ist kein Wunder, dass sie so lange ein Flash Frontend hatten,
die hatten ein Flash Frontend, bis ihnen gar nichts anderes mehr übrig geblieben ist,
und jetzt haben sie Log4j Probleme, also das ist wirklich absoluter Dreck, nicht Sabio
wohlgemerkt, ich rede nicht von Sabio, ich rede von dem anderen Asset Management Programm,
was wir haben, Bitbucket, ja Bitbucket finde ich tatsächlich ganz okay, wir steigen jetzt
glücklicherweise komplett auf GitHub um auf der Arbeit, finde ich wirklich nice, also ursprünglich
war es ja so, bei uns auf der Arbeit, ich habe irgendwann mal GitLab eingeführt, ganz,
ganz lange her, für uns zur Verwaltung, so, dann kam irgendjemand bei uns intern auf die
Idee, Bitbucket verpflichtend für alle einzuführen, haben wir gemacht und jetzt sollen wir umsteigen
auf GitHub, was ich gut finde, GitHub ist nice, warum man zwangsläufig allerdings auf GitHub
umsteigt, ich bin mir da nicht so schlüssig, weil möchte man wirklich seine ganzen Unternehmens
Source Code auf GitHub öffentlich haben, ist ja nicht öffentlich, ist ja nicht öffentlich,
ist eine GitHub Enterprise Geschichte mit Login und so, aber halt in der Cloud haben,
ob man das haben will, ich weiß es nicht, man hat sich dafür entschieden, dass man das
haben will, okay, was witzig ist, es ist ihnen dann aufgefallen, als sie alle ihre Repos von
Bitbucket nach GitHub umziehen wollten, ist ihnen dann aufgefallen, manche Leute haben
ja Hardcoded Passwörter in ihren Repos, ja die wollen wir nicht in die Cloud schaffen
und jetzt haben sie einen riesen Akt und irgendeinen Konsulten beauftragt, der unsere Repos durchsuchen
soll nach Passwörtern, ich mein, was wir Konsulten für Geld in den Hals schieben, ist echt krasser
Scheiß, okay, zwei Wochen ohne Hauptsystem ist schon kritisch, ja, es geht noch länger,
es ging ja da schon zwei Wochen nicht, vier Wochen insgesamt, sehe ich auch so, deswegen
kommt bei mir auch kein China-Chinesen Zeug ins Internet, kennst du die Leute oder kennt
ihr die Leute, die dich anschreiben in Teams und du ihnen dann antwortest, ich kann jetzt
gerade nicht oder ich habe heute keine Zeit und die einfach weiterschreiben, als hätten
sie das nicht gesehen oder aber die dann sowas hier sagen, so nach dem Motto, ach, geh doch
schnell, guck doch mal kurz, ja, wenn die Fritzbox nicht genug Ports hat, ist das ja
relativ einfach, einfach Switch dranhängen und gut ist, die Ports bei der Fritzbox intern
sind ja auch, ist ja nichts anderes als ein Switch.
Gehört deiner Meinung nach Logik in eine API oder sollte die API zugehören, weder
noch, ah, okay, kann man sich durchsteigen, also ganz ehrlich, kommt auf die Anwendung
an, wenn es was kleines ist, warum keine Logik in die API, wenn es irgendwas großes Umfang
Reiches ist, wo auch viele Leute dran arbeiten und was auch wirklich komplex ist und ausufernd
ist, dann würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt in meinen API Controller 30 Ifs reinschreiben
und da irgendwie Magic Logik machen, ja, dann hast du irgendwelche Business Logik als eigenen
Klassen und irgendwelche APIs, die im Endeffekt sich 2, 3 Sachen injecten lassen, wo sie
dann das quasi nur, nur rappen im Endeffekt, im Frontend kannst du die Logik machen, allerdings
ist halt die Frage, wie weit man die Logik im Frontend machen kann, also das Frontend
bräuchte ja dazu auch alle Daten, die das Backend hat, was ja oftmals nicht der Fall
ist, also wenn das Frontend basierte Logik ist, kann man die denke ich ohne Probleme
im Frontend machen, manche Sachen sind halt nicht sinnvoll im Frontend zu machen, zum
Beispiel, Kirby nicht ganz so laut, manche Sachen sind halt nicht sinnvoll im Frontend
zu machen, zum Beispiel, ja, ok mir fällt gerade was Aktuelles ein, gehen wir mal von
aus, kennt ihr, also muss ich anders sagen, Fernsehsender liefern ja, wenn man sie empfängt
über Tuner-EPG mit, das ist quasi so eine Programmzeitschrift, so, und mal angenommen
man möchte jetzt eine Web-Anwendung bauen, die diese Programmzeitschrift anzeigt, so
in seinem Backend macht man das Tuner-Zeugs wie auch immer, ruft den EPG ab und schreibt
vielleicht den EPG in irgendeine Datenbank rein oder sowas, fällt mir nämlich gerade
ein, weil ich mich letztens mit DVBC-Krempel beschäftigt habe und analoge lineare Fernsehtechnik
ist, nicht analoge, doch analog in dem Fall sogar, Fernsehtechnik, wobei das Bild digital
übertragen wird, abfuck ist, zumindest, stelle euch jetzt mal vor, ihr habt eine Datenbank
mit Programminformationen, jetzt müsst ihr die natürlich gescheit aufbereiten, dass
ihr die im Frontend ordentlich verarbeiten könnt, in der Datenbank steht dann zum Beispiel
drinne sowas wie ein Event pro Sendung, da steht dann da, ID 1, Sendungstitel das, Sender,
Verknüpfung, das, sowieso, so, diese Daten kriegst du aus einer Datenbank raus, schickst
du die Daten jetzt einfach so an das Frontend, dann mag das vielleicht nicht das beste Format
sein, dass das Frontend die ordentlich rendern kann, jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen, ja
es ist Aufgabe des Frontends diese Daten so umzuformen, dass man sie ordentlich rendern
kann, das Problem dabei ist nur, wenn du jetzt einen Programmzeitschrift hast mit
40.000 Einträgen, die im Frontend dann so umzuformen, dass die auch schön gerendert
werden können und das bei jedem Page Load ist vielleicht performanstechnisch nicht so
das schönste, cached man jetzt diese Anfrage auf Serverseite und macht diese Umformung
vielleicht sogar einfach serverseitig alle 30 Sekunden einmal im Hintergrund, dann ist
das Frontend deutlich schneller, also könnte man sagen, hey das sind schon Sachen die eigentlich
das Frontend machen sollte, die Daten so umformen, dass es sich gut zum Rendern eignet, aber
in dem Fall rein aus praktischen Performancegründen, wenn mein Frontend erstmal 5 Sekunden hängt,
weil es die Daten, die es von der API bekommen hat, umformen muss, dass sie es schön rendern
kann, warum nicht das auf Serverseite machen, ich glaube das ist Glaubenssache ja, aber
warum nicht, ganz ehrlich wichtig ist das, dass der Krempel am Ende funktioniert, dass
er schnell funktioniert bzw. sich gut anfühlt für den End-User, wenn er die Anwendung verwendet,
das sage ich auf der Arbeit auch öfters sinngemäß, bezieht sich dann meistens nicht so sehr auf
unsere Java-Software, aber ich habe es auch schon auf der Arbeit öfters gesagt, letztendlich
ist es unserem Außendienst oder unseren Endanwender noch vollkommen egal, wie unsere Infrastruktur
innen drinne aussieht, worauf das läuft, ob das schön programmiert ist, ob die Infrastruktur
sauber aufgemacht ist, ist denen scheißegal, was die interessiert ist, dass das zuverlässig
funktioniert und für sich gut bedienbar benutzen lässt, dass sie natürlich davon profitieren,
unbewusst, wenn das ordentlich ist, vielleicht weil es weniger Ausfälle gibt oder etwas
anderes, aber unterm Strich genommen ist das denen scheißegal, der Krempel da muss funktionieren
und das heißt, wenn man es damit hinkriegt, dass man das Frontend 5 Sekunden schneller
rendern lässt, warum nicht in die API stecken, beziehungsweise in irgendeinen Backgroundjob,
der das 30 Sekunden cached, alle 30 Sekunden neu berechnet und cached und dann schneller
das Frontend ausliefern lässt, das mag vielleicht jetzt der reine Lehre nach der falsche Ort
sein, weil das ja Frontend Sachen ist, die Backendgeschichten fürs Frontend aufzubereiten,
aber wenn man dadurch das Frontend 5 Sekunden vom Lägen abhalten kann, warum nicht, einfach
machen. Wo Fritzboxen finde ich gut sind, wobei du hast ja schon geschrieben, das macht halt
die Kombination und so Sachen wie Deckt und Voip, das will man eigentlich nicht selber
machen und da will man sich auch keine extra Geräte für kaufen, dafür ist die Fritzbox
wirklich gut. Ich meine, seriously, wer hat daheim Bock sich einen Asterisk oder irgendwas
mit Voipgeschiss selbst aufzusetzen, ich will nicht bezweifeln, dass das Leute machen daheim,
viel Spaß, viel Spaß. Wo hattest du in deiner Ausbildung die größten Schwierigkeiten? Ganz
ehrlich, meine Mitmenschen. Und mit denen habe ich immer noch die meisten Probleme, nicht
weil sie irgendwie kacke sind oder so und meine Mitmenschen irgendwie alles Drecksäcke
oder so. Ich mag das interagieren mit anderen Leuten nicht wirklich. Ich habe 2007 Fachinformatiker
System Integration gelernt. Lokal beweglicher Speicher. Mich würde interessieren, was bei
euch rauskommt, falls ihr das macht. Also wenn man Jira schon eingeführt hat und das funktioniert,
gibt es auch absolut gar keinen Sinn, dieses Tool jetzt zu ändern. Aber gut, wahrscheinlich
muss der Abteilungsleiter quasi eine Duftmarke setzen, so nach dem Motto, guckt mal hier,
ich bin neu hier und ich mache jetzt auch was Neues, weil es geht. Inlands in der Schule
Assembler, nicht schlecht, ich kenne keine Schule, die Leute hat fähig, überhaupt Assembler
beizubringen. ActiveX im Einsatz, ja wir haben immer noch ein Zeiterfassungssystem, was optimiert
ist für Microsoft Internet Explorer, weil Cloud und GitHub angesagt ist. Das mache
ich auch, Leute, ich habe das schon öfters gemacht, wenn wir die Leute zu sehr auf den
Sack gehen, du kannst dich in Teams entweder auf Do not disturb stellen oder was besser
ist, du kannst einfach auf Meet Now klicken in Teams, dann macht dir einen Meeting Raum
auf, in dem nur du bist und du schickst einfach niemanden eine Einladung, dann sitzt du in
deinem eigenen Meeting für 3 Stunden, alle denken du telefonierst und lassen dir deine
Ruhe. Five Head Time, eigentlich 11 Head ist das schon, kann ich euch nur empfehlen, wenn
euch mal wieder alle nerven, einfach eigenen Meeting Raum aufmachen. Das, oh ja, diese
sind auch schlimm. Und Leute, wo du den Teams Status siehst auf Anwesen, Abwesen, Anwesen,
Abwesen, die aber überhaupt nicht reingucken. Endanwender sind in der Regel das, die den
Kram, die den ganzen Laden bezahlen. Also Endanwender ist jetzt halt die Frage, wie
man es definiert, aber für mich ist unser Außendienst, der letztendlich Sachen verkauft,
auch für mich der Endanwender. Das ist schlimm. Zip, Voip, Gedöns, ist wirklich schwarze
Magie. Ok, wir haben es geschafft, jetzt können wir anfangen Videos zu gucken. Pog, wenn
noch was ist, schreibt es in den Chat, ich habe den da nebenbei auf. Also was gucken,
wo ist LevelCaptureBait? Ok, wir lassen uns eine Runde von LevelCaptureBaiten. Oh, zu
laut, Alter. Oh nein, please, nicht noch, Abordnet Battle Royale. Wie viele Battle Royale
Games brauchen wir eigentlich noch? Das ist fast wie die ganzen Zombie-Games, die als dieser
Dates-Hype war, wöchentlich im Minutentakt rausgekommen sind. The Day Before ist das
nicht, dieses Zombie-Ding? Moment, nee, nee, nee, das war Days Gone. Das habe ich verwechselt.
Days Gone ist das mit dem Motorrad, wo man mit dem Motorrad rumfährt und Zombies killt.
Und wo der Chef-Entwickler gesagt hat, man soll Spiele gefällig zum Vollpreis kaufen.
Das habe ich gerade verwechselt. The Day Before ist ein nächstes Zombie-Survival-MMO, das
sieht so aus, als wäre es endlich auf die Promisse von Games wie DayZ und H1Z1 gemacht,
vor fast zehn Jahren. Ich liebe Video-Games, so sehr, dass ich oft meine Essen so schnell
wie möglich machen würde, damit ich… Das ist, das ist sell-out. … wieder zurück
zum Spielen. Das heisst, ich würde meistens ein krass, unheilhaftes, gefrorenes Essen heizen.
Wenn es nur ein schnelles Essen gäbe, das heilig und gut schmeckte. Nun, heute's Sponsoren-Faktor
ist, dass das exakte Essen mit ungebrochenen, microwavable Essen direkt zu deiner Tür schiebt.
Und keine Worte, diese schmecken fantastisch und können in zwei Minuten flach werden. Es ist
wirklich schneller zu machen als ein gebrochenes Essen und sie sind eigentlich gut für dich.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, warm gemacht sieht das durchaus okay aus. Ich meine,
das ist irgendwie Hackf… Was ist das überhaupt? Okay, Essen, wo man nicht erkennt, was es ist,
ist immer schon ein bisschen sus. Das ist Hackfleisch, Hackfleisch, irgendein Lauch,
Kartoffelstückchen vielleicht? Nee, nee, nee, Erbs, nee, ähm, Mais, Mais. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Also, okay, das hier sieht deutlich besser aus als das, was man da in der Packung hatte,
wobei mir das eindeutig zu viel Brokkoli sind. Ich meine, Brokkoli, Sushini, Zucchini,
Sushini, wie heißt das richtig? Gurke, Krempel und Meatballs oder was das ist,
ist jetzt irgendwie eine weird-champige Kombination. Wie wärs mit Meatballs und Nudeln oder so?
Sushini.
Naja, dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich lieber irgendein HelloFresh denken. Okay,
HelloFresh musst du selber machen. Das ist nicht fertig. Das ist quasi,
was der uns hier zeigt, ist quasi Essen auf Rädern, wenn man so will, für die Mikrowelle.
Quasi Essen auf Rädern, eventuell. Ja gut, das ist ja, wahrscheinlich kann er einfach nicht kochen.
Leute, Zach, dazu muss ich jetzt kurz was sagen. Wir bestellen jeden Tag eine Pizza
mit Peperoni. Okay, nochmal kurz Storytime. Also, ihr wisst, ich bin selbst nicht der Dünste.
Oh, übrigens, Daily, Moment, Daily Fat Check, Sekunde, haben wir ja noch gar nicht gemacht,
nicht Daily, Weekly, Weekly Pepo Fat Check, Moment, passt auf, passt auf, Waage, Gewicht,
Copy Paste, Postchamp, Weekly Fat Check. Bald ist es so weit, Leute, bald wieder unter 100.
Ich habe angefangen bei 108 oder so, vor ein paar, vor zweieinhalb Monaten oder so. Oder vor,
ja, drei, sagen wir drei Monaten. So, zwar immer noch Pepo Fat, aber bald wieder,
wieder drei, wieder zweistellig, ja. 174. Ich bin Massive Pepo Fat, wenn man es nach dem Gewicht
geht. Ich bin zum Glück auch noch halbwegs breit, aber ich bin hauptsächlich, ich bin
sehr rund dadurch. Aber es geht runter, Leute. Also, bald unter 100 und vielleicht irgendwann
im Laufe des Jahres vielleicht zu 95 oder so. Das wäre schon sehr Pokchampig. Was machst du denn,
damit das weniger wird? Soll ich euch meine Super Meister Diät erzählen? Die ist eigentlich total
simpel. Ich bewege mich mehr und esse nur so viel, bis ich satt bin. Das ist alles. Und gesünder.
Okay, ich esse ein bisschen weniger fett, fettig. Okay, das stimmt. Also, ich esse quasi keinerlei,
keinerlei, ganz selten mal, ja, aber kaum noch Süßkram. Ich habe ja ansonsten öfters mal
irgendwie, was weiß ich, Keks, Schokoladenkram, sonst wie was gesnackt zwischendurch. Ich esse
quasi kein Süßkram mehr und ich esse nur noch quasi, bis ich satt bin. Also, jetzt esse ich
eineinhalb Teller Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce zum Beispiel. Und früher habe ich zweieinhalb
Teller gefuttert, weil es gut geschmeckt hat, ja. Aber ich bin eigentlich nach eineinhalb Tellern
satt. So. Und ich bewege mich mehr. Also mehr, zumindest, zumindest, ich bewege mich weiterhin
mindestens mal so zwei Stunden am Tag. Ich mache jetzt unbedingt kein super krasses Rumgejogge und
Fitnessstudio Workout oder sonst was. Aber ich bewege mich zwei Stunden draußen. So, fertig. Das war's.
Ich mache eigentlich fast nichts. Ich würde nicht so weit gehen und sagen, dass ich Sport mache.
Sport würde ja bedeuten, ich streng mich so sehr an, dass ich voll am schwitzen bin. Das ist es
nicht. Ich würde sagen, etwas schnelleres spazieren gehen. So irgendwie acht, acht, neun Kilometer.
Oder auch weniger, wenn es ein bisschen berghoch und bergunter geht. So um, sagen wir mal so,
zwischen eineinhalb und zwei Stunden am Tag. So. Und das reicht. Und das funktioniert für mich auch
ganz gut, weil ich hab, ich hab schon ein paar mal probiert mit deutlich weniger Essen und so was
und ich krieg das nicht gebacken. Also ich krieg das nicht gebacken. Wenn ich wirklich Hunger hab,
krieg ich das nicht hin. So. Also ich, meine Spezialdiät ist, ich hab keine Spezialdiät. Ich
bewege mich mehr und esse weniger. Fertig. Aber willst du das ganze Leben eins bis zwei Stunden
am Tag spazieren? Warum nicht? Das Beste, was man machen kann, ist, sich ein, zwei Stunden am Tag bewegen.
Was wollte ich denn eigentlich erzählen? Ich wollte doch was zu Pizza erzählen. Hier.
Also. Pizza wollte ich was erzählen. Und zwar. Ja. Also. Pizza. Und zwar. Ich hatte mal ein
Kollege, warum ich das eigentlich gezeigt hab, ist, ich bin ja selbst nicht der Dünste, ja. Aber ich
hatte mal einen Kollege auf der Arbeit. Ist schon, ist schon eine ganze Weile her. Das war auch noch
beim Provider. Also ich, nicht beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber. Der hat jeden Tag in Frankfurt,
also der kam immer erst um elf oder so. Und warum kam der erst jeden Tag um elf? Weil er von sonst
immer mit dem Auto gekommen ist. Und dass der überhaupt gescheit mit dem Auto durchgekommen
ist, musste der immer später fahren. Also der kam jeden Tag erst um elf. Warum? Weil der so gut
gebaut war, dass er keinen Platz in der Bahn hatte. Also der konnte nicht Zug fahren. Das war dem
nicht möglich. Und der hat jeden Tag auch immer auf der Arbeit Liefer, Lieferservice bestellt. Und
der hat aber so mega liefer, das hab ich noch nie gesehen. Der hat immer zweimal Pizza, zweimal
Nudeln, irgendwie zwei Flaschen Cola Fanta bestellt. Das war ein riesen Berg an Essen,
was es da gegeben hat. Und er ist auch immer erst um, keine Ahnung, um um 20, 21 Uhr wieder
heim oder so. Und das hat er den ganzen Tag dann über gegessen. Und der hat es geschafft,
die Armlehnen, das geht ins Geld, der hat es geschafft, die Armlehnen von seinem Stuhl abzusprengen.
Also Bürostuhl mit, doch kein Bürostuhl, Alter. Ja, so was in der Richtung, so was in der Richtung
war das. So und die Armlehnen, wobei, das stimmt, das stimmt so. Ihr müsst euch das vorstellen,
so ein bisschen wie hier, ein bisschen, stellt euch diesen Stuhl vor, stellt euch diesen Stuhl vor
und die waren hier unten abgesprengt, die hingen runter. Also die waren quasi hier ausgehebelt
unten und die hingen runter, die Armlehnen nur noch dahin. Ja, natürlich kann man sagen,
es ist der falsche Bürostuhl, das ist schon richtig. Es war halt, genau, es war ein Bürostuhl für alle
und das war halt nicht die, das habe ich noch nie gesehen, das habe ich noch nie gesehen. Aber eins
muss man ja sagen, insofern war der Arbeitgeber nicht schlecht, die haben ihm danach einen extra
Stuhl gekauft für die nötigen Umfang, ja. Aber das war echt krass, also das habe ich so noch nie
gesehen. Ah, und er hat auch jeden Tag, deswegen ist das Pepperoni Pizza und jeden Tag von dieser
Pizza war eine Pizza Pepperoni Pizza. Deswegen komme ich da gerade auf Pepperoni Pizza. Ja und
ich bin auch viel zu dick. Das wisst ihr, ja. Das habe ich aber noch nicht geschafft. Aber muss
man dazu sagen, mittlerweile, der Typ hat ultra krass abgenommen. Der hat, also das hat, das ist
wirklich absolut Wahnsinn. Ich habe den vor ein paar Jahren mal wieder gesehen. Der wiegt gefühlt
nur noch die Hälfte. Wie solche Leute aufs Klo gehen, das kann ich dir sagen, das habe ich
zufälligerweise auch mal gesehen. Der geht gar nicht ins Klo rein, der kann nur seitlich ins Klo
rein. Also der läuft, der lief auf die, auf die Klotür zu und dann musste der sich quasi um 90
Grad drehen und seitlich ins Klo reinlaufen durch die Tür und sich dann wieder zurückdrehen,
dass er mit dem Poppes, Richtung Poppes auf dem Klo war. Also das ging nicht anders. Zumindest der
hat richtig, richtig krass abgenommen mittlerweile. Ich weiß nicht, was er vorher gewogen hat. Keine
Ahnung. Der hat mega abgenommen und soweit ich weiß, lag das daran. Irgendwann hat er gesagt,
er hat keinen Bock mehr drauf und ist in irgendeine Selbsthilfegruppe gegangen für Essstörungen und
hat dort, das weiß ich, weil ich habe die zusammen auf der Weihnachtsfeier damals gesehen, und hat
damals ein Mädel kennengelernt, die Untergewicht, also er hatte quasi, es war eine Selbsthilfegruppe
für Essstörungen, er hatte quasi Essstörungen, er hat mega, mega viel gefuttert und war ultra
pepofett und sich hat quasi nichts gegessen. Also er hat sich nicht gegessen, er hat sich nicht
pepofett und sich hat quasi nichts gegessen und war Strich in der Landschaft. So und die haben
sich kennengelernt in dieser Selbsthilfegruppe. Er quasi mega zu dick, sie mega zu dünn. Also
ich übertreibe jetzt nicht, Leute, ich übertreibe jetzt nicht. Sein Oberschenkel war so dick wie sie
insgesamt. Kein Witz. Auf der Weihnachtsfeier habe ich das gesehen, da saß sie bei ihm auf dem
Oberschenkel und der Oberschenkel war legit, das war wie eine Bank, die konnte komplett auf dem
Oberschenkel sitzen. Also kein Ding. Also so war das Größenverhältnis. So und die haben sich da
kennengelernt und haben beide gesagt, sie wollen jetzt quasi normaleres Gewicht bekommen und ich
habe den vor ein paar Jahren wieder gesehen, der hat ultra krass abgenommen, du erkennst den
überhaupt nicht wieder. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der das ist. Jaja, das war seine Freundin.
Jaja, das habe ich jetzt vielleicht falsch ausgedrückt. Die haben sie nur kennengelernt
in der Selbsthilfegruppe, das war auch seine Freundin. Ich habe den gar nicht wieder erkannt
richtig danach, aber der hat mega abgenommen. Der sah ganz anders aus. Ich habe ihn dann schon
erkannt, aber das muss ich sagen, gut abgenommen. Der hat nicht einfach nur abgenommen, irgendwie so
wie ich jetzt mal 8 Kilo oder so. Der hat abgenommen von, ich sage jetzt einfach mal 250 Kilo oder so,
auf 90 oder so. Richtig krass. Du erkennst den Typ überhaupt nicht mehr. Echt Wahnsinn. Der hatte
schon ein bisschen, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, abgenommen, aber so krass jetzt.
Also der hat das jetzt auch wirklich 10 Jahre am Stück durchgezogen. Ja, mittlerweile sieht
er so aus wahrscheinlich. Und macht das hier. By the way, ich kann euch nur empfehlen, Leute,
wenn ihr das auch macht wie ich, ich habe das 30 Jahre lang gemacht. 10 plus Stunden am Tag am
Rechner gesessen. Leute, das beste, was ihr machen könnt, ist 1-2 Stunden am Tag einfach raus und
rumlaufen. Ihr müsst keinen heftigen Fitnessstudio machen oder sonst was. Wenn ihr wollt, natürlich.
Warum nicht? Ihr müsst euch einfach 1-2 Stunden bewegen an frischer Luft. Hätte ich das zu meinem
20-jährigen ich gesagt, hätte ich mich selbst ausgelacht. Hätte ich gesagt, willst du mich verarschen?
Kann doch nicht sein. Doch. Ihr habt keine Kreislaufprobleme, ihr habt keine Rückenprobleme,
ihr habt keine Kopfschmerzen mehr, ihr habt gar nichts mehr. Ihr müsst einfach 1-2 Stunden am
Tag raus und ein bisschen rumlaufen. Das reicht. So. Okay. Wie auch immer wir da jetzt drauf
gekommen sind, ja. Warum gibt es... Moment, diesen Kram gibt es auch zum Trinken. Yes, Smoothies habe
ich auch mal eine Weile gesoffen, bis ich da drauf gekommen bin, dass die Smoothies, die mir schmecken,
massig Zucker drin hatten und dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das muss nicht sein. Schwimmen ist
auch Bock. Ich war schon eine ganze Weile nicht mal schwimmen. Schwimmen ist auch Bock. Habt ihr
das mitbekommen? Jetzt, weil ich gerade schwimmen war, dass irgendwo Schwimmunterricht war und
irgendein Lehrer ist im Schwimmbad rumgelaufen, hatte irgendeine SS-Tattoo drauf, was dann negativ
aufgefallen ist, wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, wie bescheuert kannst du sein, wenn du sowas hast und
in Schwimmunterricht gehst. Ich meine, es kann ja sein, dass der vielleicht mittlerweile bekehrt ist
und sich halt damals tätowiert lassen hat zu seinen verwirrten Zeiten, aber dann würde ich doch
gucken, dass ich das zumindest abklebe oder so. Zumindest sind Schwimmen gegangen, das war ein
Lehrer, sind Schwimmen gegangen mit der Klasse und da hatte irgendeine SS-Tattoo, richtig hängen geblieben.
Wenn schon, sollte es zum eigenen Schutz allein schon abkleben. Und daraufhin wollten sie jetzt,
da ist das Ganze ins andere Extrem umgeschlagen, daraufhin wollten sie glaube ich in Berlin
einführen, dass jeder neue Lehrer gefälligst Fotos von allen seinen Tätowierungen machen muss,
auch aus dem Intimbereich. Oder habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das eine ist kacke, das andere ist aber
auch nicht besser. Also wie kommt man auf so eine bescheuerte Idee, Alter? Willst du das eine mit
besonders extremen Maßnahmen bekämpfen oder was? Also was zum Teufel ist mit den Leuten los? Also
wer mir das nicht glaubt, wer es mir nicht glaubt, guckt, lest euch die News dazu durch.
Was ist mit, was ist mit den los? Mal ganz davon abgesehen, muss man ja auch mal sagen,
solche Symbole sind jetzt auch schon nicht erlaubt. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als müsste man das
doppelt verbieten oder, natürlich ich verstehe, dass man solche Leute nicht als Lehrer möchte,
aber das ist ja auch so schon nicht erlaubt. Also man kann doch nicht das eine Extreme durch das
andere extreme versuchen, irgendwie zu bekämpfen, da kommt doch nichts raus. Also das ist teilweise
echt richtig, richtig hängen geblieben. Alles klar, so schauen wir mal weiter. Wir wollten das
Level Cap Video fertig gucken. Wo ist denn das Level Cap Video? Da ist es. So jetzt haben wir
das Sponsor aber geschafft. Nein, war ich nicht. Das sieht aber auch vom Kamerawinkel und sowas,
das sieht voll aus wie der Division. Die Division durch Schnurrl.
Samstag Nachmittag, das verstehe ich, ich habe auch keinen Bock, irgendwie normal ins Schwimmer
zu gehen, aber was es gibt, ist, wobei es mittlerweile geht, habe ich mich da dran,
es ist gar nicht so viel, eigentlich interessiert es keinen, wenn man ehrlich ist,
aber trotzdem, ich kann es verstehen. Es gibt ein paar vielen Schwimmbädern extra Abende für Leute,
die zu dick sind. Kannst ja mal gucken, ob es sowas bei dir auch gibt. Klar muss man sich dann
damit eingestehen, so nach dem Motto, wenn man da hingeht, man ist zu dick, aber ich glaube über
den Punkt sind wir beide raus, das wissen wir beide, dass wir zu dick sind. Und das gibt es,
gibt es mal viele Schwimmbäder, die haben extra Abende für Pepo-Fat-Leute wie uns. Das gibt es.
Und das gibt es auch relativ oft, muss mal gucken. So jetzt gucken wir das Video aber fertig. Das ist
nicht der Division, es sieht aber aus wie der Division. Du hattest vor kurzem ein Zip-Easy Bell,
das ist ein Anbieter, der macht VoIP Zeug. 2,99 Euro im Monat, Rufnummer Portier. Das ist
Fatshaming, ich sag ich bin selbst mega fett. Moment, seh ich das richtig? Level Cap erzählt
uns keine neuen Battlefield News, die keine News sind? Was ist denn da los? Dates? Nee, interessiert mich nicht so.
Massive developer publisher and powerhouse Square Enix sold off four of their biggest studios to
Embracer Group for three hundred million dollars. Square has made or published dozens of hit titles
and franchises for the Japanese market like Final Fantasy, Kingdom Hearts and Nier. But their
western franchises including Deus Ex and Tomb Raider are household names and titans of the
gaming industry. This sale mainly affects those western titles. It includes the rights to dozens
of IPs like the company's Marvel license, Dragon Quest and more. And the deal is surprising at
first glance, but it makes a lot of sense when you see how poorly some of these titles have
performed recently. Square's expectations for the games are often too ambitious. Despite selling over
three million copies in two... Too ambitious? Kann man ja auch... Okay, so kann man das auch
umschreiben dann....a healthy profit there. 2013 Tomb Raider reboot was considered a disappointment.
Their Marvel's Avengers and Guardians games grossly underperformed and cost the company over
two hundred million dollars in losses. Das war aber auch teilweise, weil das irgendwie so ein komisches
Microtransaction verseuchte Gedürfnis war. Should I just say something? Now that I just see the new Lara.
I grew up in the 90s, when the original Tomb Raider was completely sold out. And,
alter, kann man jetzt Lara please eingeplanet lassen? Und damals haben sich noch die Gamer-Webseiten
überschlagen mit irgendwie Top 10 sexiest female gaming-Gramm. Das war noch die Zeit,
da konntest du sowas schreiben, ohne direkt gekänzelt zu werden. Zumindest, nachdem ich in
dieser Zeit aufgewachsen bin, ich muss mir echt sagen, die neue Lara finde ich persönlich
deutlich ansprechender als diese übertriebene Buba-Lara aus den 90ern.
Ein weiteres Battle Royale Game, ja. Da hat die Welt aber richtig drauf gewartet.
Was meint ihr eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind? Was meint ihr denn? Hat Hazard Zone noch
Spieler? Wir gucken gerade mal, wie es Battlefield an sich geht. Oh ja, sie sind fast wieder auf ihrem
All-Time-Low angelangt. Nach dem neuen Patch hatten sie ja kurzzeitig mal 500 mehr Spieler.
Und jetzt sind sie wieder da. Was macht New World? Okay, New World ist noch mal weiter runter
getropft, Alter. Solche Fails, das ist der absolute Wahnsinn.
Blomkamp's cyberpunk aesthetic is all over the game's teaser footage. The director also has a
long history of working alongside the game industry. He was originally about to direct a
Halo movie before making District 9. And that project was so slow to get off the ground that
he produced a short film set in the Halo universe to help convince executives to speed things up.
Unfortunately, the studios involved couldn't agree on anything and scrapped the project entirely.
More recently, Blomkamp directed a trailer-style short film for BioWare's Anthem as part of his
Oats Studio production. Guck mal nach Halo Infinite, ja. Können wir auch, aber die haben halt auch einiges
verkackt. Ihr wisst, es hat mir mega Bock gemacht am Anfang. Aber was mir dann mit der Zeit, ich hatte
gar keinen Bock mehr wirklich das Game zu grinden. Dadurch, dass der Controller-Auto-Aim so mega OP ist,
naja, ähm, ja, auch nicht gut.
Destiny 2, okay. Wir gucken jetzt alles durch, Chat, weil ihr es seid. Destiny 2,
Destiny 2 geht super. Destiny 2, alles gut. Ganz ehrlich, die hatten hier erst, gab's hier eine
neue Expansion oder war das free to play oder was? Gab's hier eine neue Expansion? Warum haben die
hier so viele Spieler gehabt? Anfang des Jahres, Februar. Ansonsten würde ich ja sagen, irgendwie
Release, Expansion, Expansion. The Exes Expansion, Expansion. Ach nee, hier war einfach nur, genau.
Ja, gut, ähm, ja, das erklärt's. Aber ansonsten, ich mein, klar, dass es runtergeht, aber es ist
immer noch vollkommen im Rahmen, ja? Hält sich, klappt. Läuft.
Ey, das hier erinnert mich jetzt gerade richtig an Anthem, was auch in die Hose gegangen ist.
Ich wette mit euch, Bobby, passiert nix am Ende. Obwohl der Kerl so viel Dreck am Stecken hat,
das ist einfach feierlich. Natürlich wusste wer das. Natürlich.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde diese ganze Godzilla-Geschichte irgendwie total
deplatziert in Warzone. Das hätte ich jetzt in Fortnite gepasst.
Also allein schon dieses Rotation-Zeug, das, egal, ich fang jetzt nicht wieder vor allem
über das Game zu flippen. Also die ganzen zehn Spieler, die noch Portalspielen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist uralt. Das, das, das, das kenne ich schon. Das ist vor,
vor Jahren kam das schon raus, dass das entwickelt werden sollte. Alter, was ist das für ein Aiming hier,
was wir hier eigentlich gerade sehen? Das ist ja Pepega Aim hoch 10.
Der hat eine Sense von 30.000.
Oh, was ist wieder passiert? Hab ich mich nicht mitbekommen.
Was? Ach doch, doch, das habe ich mitbekommen. Da konnten die Coaches um die Ecken gucken und sowas,
oder? Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, das habe ich mitbekommen.
Das heißt, das haben alle gemacht.
Das ist ja quasi gecheatet. Ich meine, das ist nicht mit externer Software, aber sie haben
eindeutig irgendeinen Klitsch ausgenutzt. Naja, also das kann man sich als Coach, der bezahlt wird,
für dieses Game denken, dass wenn man auf einmal im normalen Observer Ansicht hat,
dass das nicht gewollt ist. Ja, das ist ja typische Geschichte. Das kann man immer schwer
nachvollziehen. Ja, das ist leider so. Guckt euch Bunz auf Twitch an, dass es teilweise nicht ganz
nachvollziehbar ist, warum, wie, wo, was. Aber als Außenstehender kann man das schwer beurteilen.
Geo Dreieck für 60 Euro. Ja, genau, das brauchen wir jetzt. Dates zahlen sind so hoch wie nie.
Ich weiß, haben wir letzte Woche schon raus bekommen und ich habe mich dann auch gefragt, warum? Gibt
es irgendeinen Twitch Turnier oder sowas vielleicht? Nee, einfach nur so. Spielen alle wieder Dates.
Okay Chat, habt ihr irgendwelche Videos, die wir unbedingt angucken müssen. Ansonsten lassen
wir uns jetzt erklären, in 100 Sekunden, warum Tauri besser als Elektron ist. Was haben wir
sonst noch zu? 100 plus Computer Science Concept Explained. 13.000 Euro, das krieg ich hin. Billige
Windows Key 1000. Das sollte ich mir das letzte Mal angucken, hat der Chat gesagt. Gucken wir mal.
Staubsauger Roboter, weiß ich auch, wo wir uns das angucken wollen. Was verdient ein Sales Trainer?
Vertriebstrainerin. Oh Gott, das ist wahrscheinlich einer, die mit Bullshit-Bingo Geld verdient.
Wie ich Programmieren lernen würde, wenn ich von Null starte, okay. Warum diese Armöbe menschliches
Gehirn liebt. Lego Kram. Mai Einstiegsgeiler Software Entwickler. Und irgendwelche Sachen,
die ich noch offen habe vom letzten Mal, keine Ahnung. Hat irgendjemand neue Videos, die wir
unbedingt gucken müssen? Ja, wie gesagt, das stimmt doch gar nicht. Das ist nicht Modern Warfare 2.
Es ist Modern 2 Warfare, sieht man doch eindeutig hier. The fastest way to loop in Python. Soll ich
euch sagen, was the fastest way is in Python zu loopen? Die Schleife in C zu machen und dann
aufzurufen. Interop. Was natürlich blöd ist, wenn du in der Schleife auf irgendwas zugreifen willst.
Tödlich. LED von Amazon Shop. Die sieht auch nicht so vertrauenserweckend aus,
wenn das die Außenansicht ist. Na dann gute Nacht. JQuery. Was ist da eigentlich passiert?
Kleine off-topic. Was kleine off-topic Frage. Keystone Patch Panel in Neugestalt im Heimnetzwerk.
Ja oder nein? Ich finde die Dinger nicht schlecht. Diese Keystone Sachen gibt es ja auch für viele
Sachen. Nicht jetzt gerade fürs Rack. Ich habe beispielsweise eine Netzwerkdose bei mir in Kabelkanal
eingebaut. Die wurde auch bei Keystone drauf. Ich zeige das mal kurz für alle, die nicht wissen,
was ich meine. RJ45 Keystone. Irgendein gescheites Video zu. Das hier sieht ganz brauchbar aus.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Also das setzt sich daraus zusammen. Das ist der eigentliche
Stecker am Ende. Dann so eine Auflegehilfe und das ist hinten für den Stecker von unten dran,
dass es dann Zugentlastung gibt. Den Kabelbinder kann man damit zusammen haben, braucht man aber
eigentlich nicht. So was da dran ganz praktisch ist. Du brauchst halt kein rumgegrimpe und
ekliges Gefädele im Stecker. Das ist deutlich einfacher. Also man legt, man macht die Kabel.
Wo zeigt das denn? Ja, Isolierung ab. Kabel raus. Kabel raus. Was geht es denn los? Hier. Er hat
schon gemacht. Genau. Du ziehst das durch und jetzt legst du die Farben hier auf. Guck,
da steht nämlich drunter, wie es ist. Also blau-weiß, also weiß von der dahin, blau dahin,
grün-weiß, also weiß von grün dahin, grün dahin. Dann legst du das auf. Es gibt ja zwei
Verkabelungsstandards A und B, weil es für alles mindestens zwei Standards geben muss. Ich glaube,
das unterscheidet sich hauptsächlich auch darin, wo die POE-Adern sind. Bin ich mir aber aus dem
Kopf jetzt nicht sicher. So und dann, wenn du das da aufgelegt hast, das ist halt relativ easy. Du
brauchst halt, du musst es einfach nur durchziehen und dann ist gut. So und dann legst du es auf,
dann schneidest du es ab nach dem Draufziehen. Also ziehst das da durch. Hier unten drunter,
hier drinnen sind so kleine Messer, die sich in die Kabel schneiden. Das mit dem Reinschieben
muss man gar nicht unbedingt machen, das macht der Stecker am Ende. So. Dann schneidet man außen
einmal alles ab, was übersteht und dann macht man nichts anderes, als das in den Stecker einzusetzen
und zusammenzudrücken. So einsetzen, zack, drum. Muss man gar nicht so sehr reindrücken. So,
jetzt zumachen und Stecker zumachen. Dadurch zieht sich das zusammen und klips, das ist drin. Und
dadurch, dass das Messer unten drinnen hat, also Klingen unten drin hat, schneidet sich das jetzt
automatisch ins Kabel rein und stellt Kontakt her. Fertig. Also das ist deutlich einfacher als
irgendwelche Netzwerk-Auflege-Dinger, wie man so kennt, mit Stecker und Krimpen und so. Und es
gibt dann halt auch Netzwerkdosen, die innen drin eine Halterung für genau diese Stecker haben,
ist ganz praktisch. Ja, das kann man rein machen, das hat noch ein bisschen Zugeentlastung fürs
Kabel. Das unterscheidet sich ein bisschen nach Bauart, aber das andere ist eigentlich
fast immer ähnlich. Finde ich das eine coole Sache. Fällt mir gerade auf, ich habe meinem Nachbar
vor zwei Monaten oder so mein Krimp-Krimp- und Patch-Set geliehen. Nichts davon gehört bis jetzt.
Na gut, ich brauch's auch gleich. Was daran besser ist, du kannst das ganze Fehlensparen zum
Beispiel. Wenn du das Krimpen machst, dann musst du es einfädeln von hinten in so eine
Einführhilfe, dann musst du das in diesen Stecker reinführen, dann musst du gucken,
dass alles vorne ist, dann musst du es zusammen machen, dann musst du es zukrimpen,
dann musst du es testen in der Hoffnung, dass das alles funktioniert hat. Und dann hast du
dazu einen RJ45 Stecker dran, aber den kannst du dann zwar in eine Steckdose stecken, aber da hast
du ja, achso, da sieht man hier vielleicht gar nicht, da hast du jetzt ja keinen Stecker dran
vorne, da hast du eine Buchse vorne dran, also da kannst du dann wiederum einen Stecker dranstecken.
Ist halt für Steckdosen, also für Dosen an der Wand deutlich besser und ich finde es einfacher
als selbst zu krimpen, weil gerade das, wir gucken was, gerade das Einlegen in diesen komischen
Einfädel, ja, genau, so macht man das. Ja, das Ding, genau, du musst die Kabel auseinander
machen, so, normalerweise hast du noch so eine extra Einführhilfe, dafür genau, das musst du so
machen. Moment, der ist viel zu schnell, MonkaS, das ist schon was moderneres, ok, das ist schon
was moderneres. Das was ich meine ist, Moment, das ist das gleiche Video, was ich aufgemacht
habe, oder? What? Ok, anscheinend sind die alle so pro, dass sie das einfädeln können,
ohne Einfädelhilfe, alles klar, das sind alles richtige Six-Hats, da würde ich mich so was
von vertun, normalerweise kenne ich das so, genau, so kenne ich das normalerweise, hier,
hierfür führst du die Kabel ein und das kannst du dann in diesen Checker einsetzen und das
ist abartig, richtig eklig, aber wundert mich nicht, dass es da mittlerweile neue Sachen
gibt, ja, und dagegen ist das mit diesen Keystone-Dinger echt richtige Erholung, aber ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen, dass es bessere Varianten gibt als das mittlerweile und das ist halt
die Sache, hier hast du einen Stecker, bei dem Keystone-Dinger hast du eine Buchse, hat
dann beide seine Daseinsberechtigung, wahrscheinlich, aber jeder was er will, ich mache das nicht
gerne, aber ich habe da auch bei weitem keine Übung großartig drin, ich könnte mir durchaus
vorstellen, wenn man das öfters macht, dass es relativ easy von der Hand geht. Dice is
Speedrunning Battlefield 2040 to 0 Players, ja, das ist wohl wahr. Nein, nein, nein, wir
gucken uns jetzt keinen Battlefield Geflamer an, das muss nicht sein. Chat, wir brauchen
irgendwelche Videos, die wir gucken können, sonst gucken wir jetzt das LEGO-Video, ich
guck mir jetzt das LEGO Tank an. Ne, wir gucken uns das Tauri-Video an, wir wissen was das
ist, ich weiß was es ist, das ist Elektron, bloß nicht Elektron, so viel weiß ich jetzt
schon, okay. Native ist daran gar nichts an Tauri, oder? Außer, dass es den Browser verwendet,
der vorinstalliert ist. Weirdchamp.
Naja, nur weil du es mit Rust programmierst, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das, was
am Ende dein GUI anzeigt, auch in Rust programmiert ist. Also wisst ihr, wie ich mein, also, du
kannst, ich mein, Deno ist auch in Rust programmiert und es ist Javascript im Endeffekt. Oder,
cute, das Zeug kann auch Javascript ausführen, ich, keine Ahnung, also, mal gucken. Klopp,
danke für den Zapf. Schau mal, klar.
Das ist nice, wobei die Installer-Size liegt wahrscheinlich einfach daran, weil Elektron
einen kompletten Chrome mitbringt und Tauri das vorinstallierte verwendet, oder? Und mal
ganz davon abgesehen, seriously. Zwar ernsthaft. Ich mein, für eine Hello-Welt-Anwendung,
180 MB RAM. Ich mein, es ist besser als Elektron 462. 180 MB für nix. Ist schon heftig, oder?
Es ist in der heutigen Zeit halt normal und man kann es in der heutigen Zeit machen, weil
die Leute 16 GB RAM Plus haben. Aber ich finde, für eine Hello-Welt-Anwendung, 180 MB RAM.
Man darf nicht vergessen, der N64 zum Beispiel hatte, glaube ich, mit Erweiterungskit sogar
nur 4 MB RAM. Und ein ESP32 hat aktuell, glaube ich, 400 KB RAM oder so. Also 180 MB RAM ist
schon richtig krass eigentlich für Hello-Welt. Casual Gamer HD, danke für den Zapf.
Man programmiert das in Rust, nicht in JavaScript? Okay, das heißt, es ist only for high IQ,
Leute.
Nee, doch nicht. Ah, okay, doch.
Finde ich tatsächlich fast schon ein Ticken sympathischer als, ähm, ich weiß
nicht.
Elektron, ich frage mich aber gerade, was die für einen Browser unter der Haube verwenden
unter Linux, weil unter Linux ist ja kein Browser standardmäßig vorinstalliert. Bringen
die dann was mit? Ich hoffe, die bringen nicht irgendein uralt Webkit, mit der seit zehn
Jahren outdated ist. Webview GTK verwenden die. Was ist da unten drunter? Webkit! Ja,
okay, für'n Arsch. Also, weil ich weiß, wird das überhaupt nicht mehr richtig unterstützt
und kriegt keine gescheiten Updates mehr und ist outdated seit fünf Jahren. Alter, Rust
ist einfach zu 5-Hat. Ich mein, das geht jetzt noch, das ist jetzt noch ganz gut lesbares
Rust, aber Rust ist Massive 6-Header IQ. Ich mag die Aussprache von ihm, er sagt jetzt
JavaScript. JavaScript. Ja, in Zeiten von normalen GUI-Frameworks für den Desktop war
das kein Problem. Dann konntest du auch ohne irgendwelche komischen Wrapper auf Desktop-
Funktionalität zugreifen. Heutzutage, wo man einen Browser hat, mit Node.js, V8, JavaScript-Runtime,
braucht man natürlich dafür ein extra Backend, wo man dann mit irgendwelchen Events kommuniziert,
um auf Betriebssystemen in Sachen zuzugreifen. Aber so ist das halt 2022. Native Desktop-Sachen
sacken halt und das sackt hauptsächlich, sag ich mal jetzt, weil es Microsoft nicht
gebacken bekommt, seit 20 Jahren ein neues, ordentliches Windows-Minded-Wing-Only-Native-Desktop-UI-Framework
zu bauen. Die haben mit Windows Forms damals relativ gut angefangen als Wrapper für das,
was schon da war. Dann haben sie WPF genommen, was für die damalige Zeit sicherlich coole
Sachen hatte, aber heute auch mal maßgeblich outdated ist. Ihr könnt ganz einfach testen,
wolltet ihr, ob ein GUI-Framework modern ist und funktioniert, macht, pastet Emojis rein
und guckt, ob der die in ordentlicher Schrift, in ordentlicher Farben anzeigt. Kann WPF nicht,
außer mit Zusatzdingern, wo sie tricksen. Ja, und WPF hat ein paar andere Dinge. Aber
danach hat Microsoft gesagt, wir machen UWP. BAUI wird genauso Müll wie Xamarin Forms
vorher war. Danach haben sie gesagt, wir machen UWP und das hat Microsoft acht Jahre oder so
durchgezogen, seit Windows 8, wo das, glaube ich, angefangen hat. Wann kam Windows 8? Seit
zehn Jahren haben die das durchgezogen und irgendwann haben sie dann eingesehen, keine
Sau will UWP verwenden. Ja, und sie haben die Chance mit WinUI, endlich das mal richtig zu
machen, aber sie schaffen es nicht. Das ist ja bis heute nicht raus. Es ist bis heute nicht
raus und sie haben auch gerade diese Sache mit, du kannst Native Desktop Anwendungen machen
ohne Client-Zertifikat. Immer wieder rausgeschoben, immer wieder verschoben bei WinUI 3 und es
so verwirrend gemacht, dass ich bis heute noch nicht mal weiß, ob es überhaupt mittlerweile
geht. Gehen in WinUI 3 mittlerweile Native Desktop Anwendungen ohne Packaging, ohne Client-Zertifikat-Geschiss.
Einfach ganz normale Windows Desktop Anwendungen. Wenn die gehen und nicht ultraverbackt sind,
ist das gut. Ich traue es Microsoft nach all der Zeit nicht mehr zu. So Xamarin Forms kannst
du knicken, weil ich finde den Ansatz von Xamarin Forms, beziehungsweise MAUI ist es
ja dann, vom Ansatz her nicht gut, weil was die machen ist, sie nehmen Native UI Frameworks,
also sowas wie GTK auf Linux oder VPF auf Windows oder UVP auf Windows oder was ist
es auf Mac? Cocoa? Nee, wie heißt das Ding auf Mac? Keine Ahnung. Zeug und Wrappen die
Native UI Elemente. Das ist halt Crap, weil dann hast du das Problem, dann hast du Native
Mac Elemente, Native GTK und Native Windows Elemente und musst irgendwie den kleinsten
gemeinsamen Männer rappen. Das ist komisch und selbst das funktioniert nicht richtig,
weil ich letztens mal auf Reddit geguckt habe, wo sich einer über MAUI aufgeregt hat und
er hat die Checkboxen unter macOS gezeigt und die sahen total kaputt aus. Vielleicht
haben sie es auch mittlerweile so gemacht, dass sie selbst ihre GUI Elemente malen können,
aber das funktioniert nicht. Also ein gutes Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework und da können
wir uns jetzt Electron als Beispiel nehmen, weil die machen es gut, weil sie sind auf
Browser-Basis und auf Browser-Basis ist das von Haus aus mit dabei oder wir können uns
Qt angucken oder Flutter oder sonst was. Was ein gutes Cross-Plattform-GUI-Framework machen
muss, ist den kleinsten, also den Low-Level-Ansatz pro Plattform fahren. Du nimmst OpenGL, DirectX
oder irgendwie sowas wie Skia oder was auch immer. Du nimmst irgendeine Low-Level, am
besten 2D, 3D beschleunigte Graphik-Library und dann malst du deine Controls selber, weil
nur so kannst du sicherstellen, dass dein UI-Framework ordentlich funktioniert und überall
ordentlich ausschaut. Dieses Gerappe von Rappern von Native-UI-Elementen funktioniert nicht.
Und ja, dieser ganze Kremfeld drum herum mag ich eh nicht, mochte ich bei WPF noch nicht
und jetzt bei Maui auch nicht. Ja, also deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass es was wird. Und ich
traue das Microsoft auch nicht zu, dass sie da irgendwas Gescheites hinbekommen in der
Richtung. So. Das probieren wir mal aus. Das probieren wir Just for Fun mal aus demnächst.
Ja, das ist so. Aber gerade wenn du die Native-UI-Elemente rappst, so wie das Xamarin oder Maui
macht, ist das noch ekliger. So, wenn du nämlich deine eigenen UI-Elemente malst, dann sieht
das vielleicht nicht so richtig passend aus, dass du sagst, ja das sieht aus wie eine Native-Mac-Anwendung
oder Native-Windows-Anwendung, aber es sieht einheitlich aus. Du kannst zumindest gucken,
dass deine Anwendung einheitlich gut bedienbar ist und dass mittlerweile das UI in jeder Anwendung
ein bisschen anders aussieht. Da haben sich die Leute eh schon dran gewöhnt, weil jede
Webseite kocht sein eigenes Süppchen und in jeder Elektron-Anwendung auch. Also schlechter
wird es dadurch schon mal gar nicht. Übrigens, das hier, wisst ihr in was OBS programmiert
ist? Also ich kann es euch sagen. Vielleicht weiß das jemand von euch. Also meines Wissens
nach ist, ach nee, ich meine nicht die Programmiersprache, ich meine UI-Framework. Also meines Wissens
nach ist das Qt mit ziemlich viel FFM-Pack. Das müsste man vielleicht auch hier sehen
in About. License? Keine Ahnung. Also meines Wissens nach ist das Qt und ziemlich viel
FFM-Pack. Das alte OBS, also nicht OBS Studio, das alte OBS davor war glaube ich noch Direct
Show Windows Only mit WPF, nee nicht WPF, kann sogar Windows Forms gewesen sein, ich
weiß es gar nicht, GUI. Aber das neue ist glaube ich Qt-Oberfläche mit ganz viel FFM-Pack
dabei. Ich meine man sieht das dem Ding auch an, das ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das hier
absolut Pleading Edge GUI Design. Aber was du dem Ding auch gut ansiehst ist, es ist
halt definitiv auch kein Browser. Das merkst du sofort. Ich kann schlecht sagen woran man
es erkennt, aber ich sehe sofort ob das irgendein Browser ist, der eigentlich so tut als wäre
es eine Desktop Anwendung oder eine Desktop Anwendung. Ich kann es schwer beschreiben
woran man es erkennt, aber das Ding hier siehst du sofort, das ist kein Browser. Wohingegen
Wishless Studio Code aufgemacht, erkennst du sofort. Am Fond Rendering, am Feeling von
der Oberfläche erkennst du sofort, das ist ein Browser. Ich kann euch nicht genau sagen
woran ich das so instinktiv merke, aber ich will auch nicht sagen, dass ich da immer richtig
liege. Schwer zu sagen woran es liegt, aber man merkt es. Ich weiß aber echt nicht woran
man das erkennt. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es gibt natürlich auch Zwischlinger, der neue
Explorer zum Beispiel. Gerade hier oben, das könnte vielleicht ein Browser sein,
aber das hier unten dann schon wieder nicht. Warum habe ich mein eigenes Video runtergeladen?
Löschen. Kann man in diesem nichts löschen oder was? Das ist weg.
Open. Es ist nicht mehr da. Recent Files, verschwinden gelöschte Sachen nicht, ok alles
klar. Was auch immer. Teams Notification Sounds, meinst du den hier? Ja, das ist tatsächlich
wahr. Ich muss auch sagen, ich habe nicht viel Erfahrung mit, aber das ist mir schon
auch aufgefallen, dass die meisten Anwendungen auf dem Handy mittlerweile zumindest vermute
ich, dass Browser basierte Sachen sind, aber auf dem Handy finde ich es tatsächlich gar
nicht so wild. Da geht das. Und wenn ich irgendeine Mobile Anwendung entwickle, würde ich auch
im Leben nicht eine native Java Kotlin Anwendung machen für Android und eine native iOS Swift
Kaste nicht gesehen Anwendung. Da würde ich irgendeine, ja, gibt es ja alles mögliche.
Ionic, der React Native würde ich nicht machen, weil ich von React keine Ahnung habe. Flutter,
Alter. Flutter. Flutter würde ich auch nicht machen, weil ich Dart nicht großartig kann
und Flutter mir nie wahnsinnig viel mit beschäftigt hat, außer mal dieses Mini Anwendung, die
wir getestet haben hier im Stream. Ich würde wahrscheinlich irgendwie Nuxt oder sowas
nehmen, weil ich weil ich ganz gut kann oder Ionic oder irgendwas. Keine Ahnung. Ich würde
aber nicht mit native Anwendung auf mobile anfangen. So was gucken wir uns jetzt an
Chat? Was wird denn jetzt geguckt? Dice. Nein. Dice. Irgendjemand hat gesagt ein Video wäre
nice. Das müssen wir gucken. Was verdient ein Sales Manager? Ich weiß Leute, wenn ich
das Video gucke, dann muss ich flamen, weil es wahrscheinlich jemand ist, der Geld verdient
mit Bullshit Bingo. Ich will das gar nicht gucken. Wie ich programmieren lernen würde,
wenn ich von Null anfange. Jetzt konnten wir uns tatsächlich angucken. Ganz ehrlich, ich
würde den Browser nehmen, Editor und JavaScript. Das Video ist richtig keck weh. Welches? Das
mit dem Sales Manager? Mit der Sales Managerin? Sales Training? Ok, wenn ihr das seid, wir
gucken uns das jetzt an. Das ist BWL Krempel, Alter. BWL Krempel. Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich mit 34 dieses Leben habe. Bestes Leben. Es ist schon wichtig, aber es ist nicht
das Wichtigste für mich. Geld ist wichtig, es ist nicht das Wichtigste. Das sagen immer
nur Leute, die Geld haben. Lohnt sich das. Hi, ich bin Maria Azzarone und bin selbstständige
Vertriebstrainerin aus Stuttgart. Ok, was ich schonmal gut finde, dass die nicht irgendein
Nebalsystem, Stonksmensch dahingestellt haben, weil das ist das, was sich die meisten Leute
unter Vertrieb vorstellen. Irgendein Schema-Pyramiden-Modelltyp, der erzählt, gewinne, gewinne, gewinne, gewinne
und sowieso. Zumindest jemand, der das halbwegs seriös betreibt. Ein Kaffee am Morgen ist
wichtig, ne? Nee, trinke keinen Kaffee. Trinke immer einen Kaffee. Eine Vertriebstrainerin
ist eine Trainerin, die den Verkauf trainiert, wirklich. Also Menschen, die im Verkauf arbeiten,
die trainiere ich, dass sie mehr verkaufen. Ich mache ganz unterschiedliche Sachen von
Seminaren über Coaching, über Begleitung, über Konzepte schreiben. Also man könnte
sagen, wie man die Leute besser scammen kann, wobei das ja gar nicht wahr ist. Ein guter
Verkäufer, zumindest meiner Ansicht nach, ein guter Verkäufer verkauft den Leuten was,
was sie auch brauchen bzw. wo sie danach wiederkommen. So One-Way-Verkäufer können viele, aber Verkäufer
zu sein, dass man den Leuten was verkaufen kann, dass sie zufrieden sind und danach wiederkommen,
das ist glaube ich das, womit du auch Kohle machen kannst und was nicht jeder kann. Also
was wirklich schwierig ist. Ich habe ziemlich Anfang 20 meinen Papa verloren, Anfang 30
meine Mama und ja, ich habe gesehen, dass es mir nicht eben steht und dass wir nicht machen
sollen, die uns Spaß machen. Ich habe nie gedacht, dass ich mit 34 dieses Leben habe,
niemals. Was auch gut ist, ich bin frei, ich kann tun und machen, was ich will, aber natürlich
weh mir auch meine Eltern. Ja, aber das hat, das hat ja also, das hat ja nichts damit zu tun,
als jetzt Vertriebsleiter, egal. Und ausscannen mit den Produkten, die man verkauft, ja. Dann
geh mal hoch ins Büro, dann bereite ich alles vor und um 10 ist ja mein erstes Meeting. Meeting,
immer wichtig. Wo ist das coaching? Morgen. Ich bin mal gespannt, was man, das meine ich
jetzt ernst. Ich bin wirklich gespannt, was man als Sales, Training, Konsulten quasi verdient.
Ich tippe darauf, es ist entweder viel weniger als ich denke oder brutal viel. Wahrscheinlich
ist das irgend so ein Ding, wo es dazwischen kaum gibt. Meine Post würde ich auch noch abholen.
Sie leise oder? Super, ich danke dir. Passt doch. So, das bereiten wir uns ein bisschen vor. Ein
Büroraum. Also so sieht so mein Arbeitsplatz aus, genau. Double Laptop Setup. Sie sitzt in
Luxemburg, sie ist da eine Filialeiterin von einer Haarentfernung, von einem Haarentfernung
Institut. Warte, Haarentfernung. Ich bräuchte ein paar Haare. Gibt es auch das Gegenteil? Gibt
es Einpflanzung oder so? Ich könnte gerade so in der Mitte hier. Ich meine, weil ihr kennt das ja.
Ihr kennt ja dieses dieses Foto denke ich irgendwo. Real Life. Das ist das ist der Selfon. Wo ist denn
dieses Foto, was ich im Kaboom aufgenommen habe? Foto liegt, alles klar. Wo ist denn,
wo ist denn das? Wurde ich da geleakt? Okay, keine Ahnung. Das Foto, wo ich von hinten
fotografiert, wo ich im Kaboom unten in der im Keller gehockt habe. Da hatte ich schon
wenig Haare hinten und mittlerweile habe ich noch weniger. Das heißt, ich bräuchte keine
Haarentfernung, ich bräuchte eher Haareinpflanzung. Natürlich wieder Beratungsgespräche, muss sehr
viel beraten, muss verkaufen. Die müssen um die 5000 Euro pro Woche erreichen, genau. Und die
arbeiten ja fünf Tage, also 1000 Euro pro pro Arbeitstag müssen die erreichen. Und da gibt es
natürlich manchmal Schwierigkeiten, warum erreichen die das nicht? Ja, manchmal gibt es halt Leute,
die wollen einfach nichts verkauft bekommen, soll vorkommen. Ich hätte so keinen Bock drauf,
Verkäufer zu sein. Gerade Verkäufer, wo es nicht darum geht, jetzt quasi Leute zu beraten und denen
was Sinnvolles zu verkaufen, sondern um denen, um denen was aufzuschwätzen. Das könnte ich nicht,
da bin ich nicht geeignet für. Nicht jetzt, weil ich sagen würde, ah hier mein Gewissen gibt das
nicht her oder so. Weiß ich nicht. Eher, weil ich mit Leuten gar nicht so gut reden könnte,
dass die von mir überhaupt so viel kaufen würden. Und dann auch mit Leuten kommunizieren den ganzen
Tag. Ich würde denen wahrscheinlich bei jedem zweiten Gespräch erzählen, wie dumm sie sind
und sie abhauen sollen, aber das wäre halt als Verkäufer nicht gut. Wie die Woche war,
wie die Zahlen waren, wie viele Beratungstermine waren. Grüß dich, hast du mich? Hi. Und wie
viele Beratungsgespräche hattet ihr die Woche? Der ist aber ganz schön beschlagen, der Monitor,
oder? Oder wie viel hattest du? Wir sind ja jetzt erst Donnerstag, aber wir hatten jetzt diese Woche
vier. Darum haben wir auch drei sofort abgeschlossen. Okay, nur mal, dass ich das richtig verstehe. Die
muss 5000 Euro am Tag packen und die gibt quasi einen kompletten Tageslohn für Coaching aus. Nice.
Ja, genau. Und die letzte, da haben wir besprochen, dass wir erst im Oktober anfangen damit. Aber warte
mal ganz kurz. Machen wir uns da bitte auch einen Termin, dass wir die nachtelefonieren? Dass man
sagt, okay, was ist der Grund, warum sie an uns zweifeln? Warum buchen sie nicht jetzt gleich so
kurz? Das ist auch geil. Als Berater musst du... Okay, du bekommst als Berater 700 Euro pro Termin
und dann sagst du ihm, können wir da bitte auch noch einen Termin? Nein, wenn die Sachen nicht
machen, kann wir bitte einen Termin? Die sagt es ja so, du machst jetzt gefälligst mit mir noch
einen weiteren Termin. The fuck? Würde ich aber auch so machen. Ich meine, damit zeigt sie,
sie kann nicht nur gut verkaufen. Sie verkauft auch, während sie andere Coach zu verkaufen. So
musst du es eigentlich machen. Du musst gleich noch ein bisschen Kohle absahnen dabei. Board,
genau, ist bei mir schon wichtig. Wenn die Standorte nicht abliefern, wenn die Kunden
ausbleiben und am Ende wir Standorte schließen müssen, das wäre das Schlimmste, was passieren
kann. Aber die Umsätze an sich sind gut. Also wir haben ja so circa 5000 Euro pro Woche. Wie
ist es denn bei dir? Also kommst du auf dein Wochenziel. Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig. Okay,
ich guck mir jetzt mal noch mal die Zahlen durch von allen Bereichen und ich würde sagen, dass wir
in zwei Wochen nochmal sprechen. Dann bis zum nächsten Mal. Und auch dieses Kontrollieren
wird mir voll auf den Sack gehen. Also ich meine, bei uns ist es natürlich auch so, wenn du
irgendwelche Tickets bearbeitest, dass dann vielleicht irgendwann auch mal einer drüberguckt,
so nach dem Motto, hier guck mal, an diesen Ticket waren 20 Leute beteiligt und es liegt jetzt
seit fünf Wochen rum und keiner macht was und so. Ja, okay. Aber so dieses permanente Kontrollieren,
das wird mir mega auf den Sack gehen. Aber generell, generell ohne Miss,
dieses ganze Außendienst, Salesgedöns, so Vertriebssachen, das ist, das ist für mich,
ich mag die meisten Leute nicht aus diesem Bereich und ich könnte mir selbst null vorstellen,
das zu machen. Ich muss ja auch abliefern, das ist ja nicht so, dass ich da nur mit denen ein
bisschen spreche und das war's. Ich muss die trainieren, ich muss die Fähigkeiten aneignen
und die müssen das abliefern. Das ist meine Aufgabe als Betriebstrainerin, genau. Also es
fällt ja eigentlich auch auf dich zurück. Eigentlich, was ich bisher gesehen habe, ist nicht,
dass sie die Leute trainiert, sondern, dass sie den Leuten Druck macht, gefälligst mal mehr
zu verkaufen. Also es ist doch weniger Training, das ist doch mehr Angst machen als Training,
was man bis jetzt gesehen hat oder sich das falsch. Das ist quasi eher den Leuten noch einreden,
jetzt mach das mal gefälligst, sonst gibt's Ärger, wenn du dein Ziel nicht erreicht,
weniger Training, wie kann ich gut verkaufen? Das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Definitiv, wenn der Kunde in mich investiert und kein Mehrwert hat, bin ich raus, ganz einfach,
genau, das auf jeden Fall. Ich kann hier auch euch mal das zeigen. Ich hätte ganz
mal, vielleicht kommt es ja noch. Also ich hätte ja von einem Sales Training quasi erwartet,
dass man zum Beispiel sagt, ja, letztens habe ich mit irgendeinem Kunde telefoniert und an
der Stelle hatte ich keine gute Antwort parat, haben sie da irgendeinen Tipp für, wie ich die
Situation besser handeln kann oder wie ich das vielleicht, das Gespräch auf eine andere Bahn
lenken kann, dass man da sowas übt, aber doch nicht. What the fuck?
Zum Beispiel hat sie die Woche um die 1,6, hier 900, das ist halt viel zu wenig. Jetzt haben wir
gleich mit dem Murat von Eden Beauty, das ist der Geschäftsführer, einen Zoom Call. Ich werde ihm
berichten, wie die Wochen waren mit den Mitarbeitern, was alles ansteht, wie das Gespräch gerade
wunderbar genau und wie die Zahlen sind, wo wir dran arbeiten müssen. Hallo Murat, grüß dich.
Ah, der lässt sich filmen. Das ist einer meiner wichtigsten Kunden. Hat er da irgendeinen?
Was hat er denn hier als Overlay auf diesem Display?
Ach nee, das ist ein Hintergrund.
Bist du gerade in der Schweiz? Das ist einer meiner wichtigsten Kunden, da es international
aufgestellt ist, verschiedene Standorte in Europa hat und gerade auch Wachstumskurs ist.
Wir haben schon gesprochen auf jeden Fall. Super Wachstumskurs, ja? Treib deine Leute in den
Burnout und mach sie fertig, wenn sie nicht abliefern. Das ist natürlich geil, Storks Wachstum,
so mag ich das. Sie sehen, dass sie nicht so viele Beratungen hat die Woche. Ich habe mir
jetzt noch mal die Zahlen angeguckt, Murat. Also da schwanken welche auf jeden Fall. Ich werde noch
mal mit allen sprechen. Ich werde noch mal genau definieren, was wir ausgemacht haben.
Boah, ich hasse diese Branche einfach nur. So ätzend.
Wir gucken uns das an und dann müssen wir gucken, wer die Sachen annehmt, umsetzt und wer eben nicht.
Das ist mir wichtig. Das ist eine große Schere. Ja, genau.
Mit Mitarbeit. Hat Murat vielleicht mal dran gedacht? Ich weiß nicht, was die verkaufen,
ja? Wäre vielleicht die Möglichkeit, dass ihre Produkte scheiße sind und die keiner kaufen will?
Ich weiß nicht, was die herstellen. Vielleicht sind deswegen die Zahlen nicht so gut. Wäre
ja auch eine Möglichkeit. Vielleicht ist einfach das Produkt Müll.
Siehst du auch, was die Woche die einen leisten und die anderen, das geht halt nicht. Genau,
da müssen wir halt gegen ansetzen. Die machen Haarentfernung.
Vielleicht entfernen sie die Haare nicht richtig. Keine Ahnung.
Wenn ich im Internet Bewertungen gucke und die Bewertungen werden schlecht,
wie heißen die? Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken. Hat jemand mitbekommen,
wie dieses Unternehmen heißt? Irgendwas in der Schweiz. Haarentfernung.
Da haben wir auch Google Eden. Was? Eden Beauty. In Frankfurt. Moment, die gibt es in Frankfurt.
Okay, die haben gute Bewertungen. Alles klar. Dauerhaft Haarentfernung. Okay,
die scheinen das nicht schlecht zu machen. Moment, die haben nur drei Bewertungen. Das
sagt nicht wirklich viel aus. Ja, aber die scheinen das doch ganz okay zu machen.
Wie verkauft man denn Haarentfernung? Rufen die Leute da an und sagen,
ich würde mich gerne beraten lassen über Haarentfernung oder rufen die
Leute aus irgendeinem Telefonliste an und sagen, hey, haben sie schon mal drüber nachgedacht,
sich Haare entfernen zu lassen oder was? Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Ich meine,
das ist jetzt ja irgendwie kein, ich verkaufe dir Staubsauger oder so. So,
hallo, wie sieht es aus? Brauchen sie ihre Haare noch oder? Tschüss, machs gut, tschüss.
Also im Prinzip, die Leute rufen da an. Die Leute rufen da an und sagen, ja,
ich habe zu viel Haare am Bobbes und dann sagen die, ja hier, das ist ganz super,
lassen sie sich doch Brusthaare auch entfernen bei uns und dann verkaufen die quasi doppelt so viel.
Also die schwätzen den Leuten quasi mehr Haarentfernung auf, als sie eigentlich bräuchten
oder wollen oder so. Ja gut, dafür braucht man gute Verkäufer. Da bin ich mal gespannt,
wie man da Leute davon überzeugt. Das sieht sehr gesund aus, so Tofu oder sowas. Jetzt
geht es gleich zum nächsten Termin, wobei eher Reis und Schnitzel. Ich habe die Inhalte dabei,
wir müssen noch mal ein bisschen das abstimmen. Oh, da ruft mich gerade jemand an,
ich gehe dann einfach mal ran. Als Berater, das ist was, was mich auch übelst abschreckt,
als Berater ist es eigentlich egal. Die rufen auch Leute irgendwie am Sonntag ran. Lohnt es
nicht, von VDSL auf Glasfaser zu wechseln? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dann am besten mir eine
e-Mail schicken. Ok, vielen Dank. Danke schön. Das war Mercedes-Benz Consulting. Die suchen einen Salesredner international und jetzt
kam gerade, dass sie mich gerne kennenlernen wollen. Mal gucken, vielleicht klappt es ja.
Also jetzt gehen wir Richtung Degaloch hoch. Das ist eine Kundin von mir, die hat einen Verband,
die machen verschiedene Seminare und ich mache dieses Jahr drei Stück. Heute geht es natürlich
um auch die Präsentation durchzusleiten und einfach nochmal Kleinigkeiten zu verändern. Mein netter
Umsatz lag letztes Jahr bei 44.000. Wir hatten letztes Jahr noch Corona, deswegen habe ich eine
Corona-Hilfe von 7.000 Euro bekommen. Ich hatte Betriebsannahmen von 51.000. Ok, das ist nicht so viel,
wie ich gedacht hätte. Ich hatte Betriebsausgaben von 17.000. Dann musste ich natürlich Umsatzsteuer
noch bezahlen. Das ist wirklich gar nicht so berauschend. Mein Gewinn lag dann bei 29.000. Das ist wirklich nicht so
berauschend. Hallo. Hi Katja. Davon musst du ja noch Steuern bezahlen. Ich glaube, das ist besser, weil ich ein bisschen was vorbereitet
habe. Wir haben auch einen Hund da. Da bleiben wir am Ende. Da bleiben wir am Ende irgendwie. Gut, das kommt drauf an.
Was sonst? Was weiß ich? 2500 Euro oder irgendwie? Nee, weniger wahrscheinlich. So 1000 Euro oder irgendwie.
2000 Euro oder sowas. 2000 Euro, irgendwie sowas. Also jetzt geht es darum, dass wir die Seminare
nochmal abstimmen müssen. Die Inhalte, genau. Ich habe ja alles vorbereitet. Ja, auf jeden Fall passt. Das muss ich noch
etwas umändern. Wenn sie sagt, das ist alles scheiße, muss ich die ganze Transformation nochmal machen.
Dann habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Ich habe 16 Stunden schon investiert. Wir haben ja diese zwei Seminare,
die wir dieses Jahr planen. Genau, ich habe da schon ein bisschen was dran fertig gemacht. Ich würde gerne mit dir
das kurz durchsliden, wenn es okay ist. Ich gehe einfach mit dir mal durch. Ich kriege Ausschläge bei diesen Marketing-Leuten immer.
Ich kann es nicht beschreiben, was es ist, aber wenn ich so Marketing-Leute sehe, kriege ich irgendwie das Gefühl,
ich muss schnell weg. Passt. Oder ob ich nochmal irgendwas umändern soll, genau. Also was ist überhaupt eine starke Persönlichkeit?
Darüber sprechen wir. Wie kann ich mehr Selbstwert gewinnen? Selbstvertrauen? Chat, reist euch zusammen.
Wie kann ich meine Persönlichkeit ja auch weiterentwickeln, wenn ich meine Komfortzone verlasse?
Gerade im Vertrieb geht es ja auch darum, dass wir immer neue Ziele erreichen. Das hört sich jetzt voll wenig
für euch an, aber ich alleine dieses Jahr mache ungefähr 60.000 bis 80.000 Euro Umsatz. Ich finde es nicht wenig für mich,
weißt du, wie ich meine. Also ich habe ja noch kein großes Unternehmen und ob ich jetzt angestellt wäre oder selbstständig,
ich glaube, ich hätte nicht viel mehr Spielraum als Angestellter. Also was für uns da vielleicht auch noch ganz wichtig wäre,
weil wir ja explizit das auch für die Frau machen, dass wir so ein bisschen das Thema Frau im Vertrieb auch bewerben.
Ok, auch die Vorteile als Frau im Vertrieb zu arbeiten. Ok, super, das werde ich einplanen.
Was mir auch nochmal wichtig wäre, Maria, das wäre ganz schön, wenn du das machen könntest, dass du vielleicht nochmal,
bevor wir quasi ins Seminar einsteigen, so drei bis fünf Fragen machst, was die Erwartungshaltung an das Seminar ist.
Ich habe eine blöde Frage. Warum genau, also wenn die Rechte doch genau die rechte Frau, die Blonde,
wenn die doch genau weiß, was da rein muss, rein soll, warum machen die diese Präsentation für die Leute denn nicht selber?
Warum muss man denn quasi so um die Ecke eine Präsentation beauftragen und dann der sagen, was die reinschreiben soll?
Hä?
Was auch immer.
Ok, das war es von meiner Seite. Spitze, prima.
Es war wichtig, dass wir uns heute getroffen haben, weil ich dachte, wir werden so durch, aber ich muss noch ein bisschen was machen,
dass das so passt. Soll ja auch ein erfolgreiches Seminar werden, deswegen fand ich es wichtig.
Super, nein, sehr gerne. Immer wieder gerne. Danke, kein Schlaf.
Es wirkt auch alles so, ich weiß, diese ganze Marke, das wirkt alles so gezwungen immer, aber gut, ich bin ja nicht der richtige Führer,
aber ganz ehrlich, ich kann dieser ganzen Marketing-Verkaufs-Laber-Branche eh nix abgewinnen.
Gut, es war kein perfektes Gespräch. Perfekt wäre, wenn sie überzeugt von mir wäre.
Sie hat ja noch ein paar Dinge erkannt, die ich verändern muss und das werde ich machen und nur dann kann es auch erfolgreich sein.
Vielen Dank nochmal, tschau. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Ich danke, freue mich, dass du wiederfällig bist.
Die sind aber am Schütteln hier.
Danke dir, tschau.
Tschüss.
Also ich zahle mir ca. 2000 Euro netto aus jeden Monat.
Mir ist Geld schon wichtig, weil ich alleine bin, aber es ist nicht das Wichtigste.
Also ganz im Ernst, das ist ungefähr das, was wir eben geschätzt haben, oder?
Ungefähr 2000 Euro kommen dann im Endeffekt rum am Ende.
Dafür würde ich mir das nicht geben.
Aber das ist auch was, was mir zutiefst wieder strebt, sowas.
2000 Euro netto aus jeden Monat, ja.
Mir ist Geld schon wichtig, weil ich alleine bin, aber es ist nicht das Wichtigste für mich.
Ich bin 34, ich habe keine Eltern mehr, ich habe keinen Partner.
Was bringt mir das große Geld, wenn ich da, wisst ihr, Geld kommt und geht.
Ich kann viel davon verdienen und auch viel verlieren.
Das Allerwichtigste ist doch, dass man Menschen hat, die, wisst ihr, wenn ich an meine Eltern denke, auch wenn sie heute...
Ich will keine Menschen.
Lasst mich in Ruhe mit Menschen, Alter.
Wenn wir da sind, das berührt mich, das bewegt mich.
Die haben was bewegt in mir, die haben mich so geformt, wie ich heute bin.
Und das ist doch das Schönste, was man hinterlassen kann.
Also ich habe jetzt noch einen Englischunterricht, genau um 19 Uhr mit der Katie.
Die kommt aus Amerika, mit der spreche ich oder mit der lerne ich Businessenglisch.
Genau, weil ich einfach international arbeiten möchte und sie beratet mich auf diese Trainings vor.
Hi, Katie.
Ist das irgendein Gruppencall?
Es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall und ich bin so so dankbar, dass ich diese Chance im Leben ergriffen.
Also ich muss sagen, ich kann dieser Branche null abgewinnen und ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock auf sowas zu machen.
Und ich habe mir das Video jetzt angeguckt und muss sagen, also mein Fall ist es nicht.
Na, das geht natürlich immer nicht gegen die Leute, die man da sieht.
Ich kenne die Leute ja alle persönlich nicht.
Ach, diese Marketingbranche ist es echt nicht meins.
Ich bin mega stolz darauf, was ich mache und ich glaube, ich mache das auch ziemlich gut.
Sonst wäre ich nicht nach fünf Jahren immer noch so erfolgreich.
Wir haben bei uns ja auf der Arbeit auch öfters irgendwelche Stompsberatungskonsultansleute
und da ist so unglaublich viel heiße Luft dabei.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Ihr Lieben, ich hoffe, ihr habt Spaß gehabt beim Zuschauen.
Deshalb abonniert unbedingt den Kanal hier und wenn ihr noch weitere Videos...
Was? Ein agiler Gründer?
Ach nee, ein Agenturgründer.
Ich habe gesagt, was verdient ein agiler Gründer?
Das hätten wir uns natürlich angeguckt, was ein agiler Gründer verdient.
Was? Ein Agenturgründer?
Ich habe gesagt, was verdient ein agiler Gründer?
Das hätten wir uns angeguckt, was ein agiler Gründer verdient.
Nee, Chet, also ich weiß...
Ich an sich glaube ich, ich fand die gar nicht so unsympathisch.
Ich fand diesen Job mega, weiß nicht, nicht mein Fall, ja.
Und eins ist klar, ob es jetzt so meint oder nicht, wissen wir nicht.
In solchen Positionen, du musst...
Und das habe ich bei unseren Consultants und bei unseren Beratern auch schon gemerkt.
Du musst immer selbstsicher und überzeugend tun, immer.
Egal, wie wenig Ahnung du hast, wenn du nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung hast,
du musst dich hinstellen und musst es selbstsicher und überzeugend,
als wüsstest du, was du machst, sagen.
Und das hat die halt auch schon komplett drinne.
Also selbst wenn sie keine Ahnung hat, das ist ihr Job,
die muss so tun, als hat sie immer Plan.
Das geht mir bei unseren Consultants auch teilweise auf den Sack, ja.
Gerade im technischen Bereich, unsere Consultants, die wir da teilweise haben,
frage ich mich ernsthaft, ich wüsste nicht zu welchem Punkt
ich den eigentlich konsultieren würde normalerweise, aber okay.
Never do this nested if statement is so bad.
Kommt auf den Bereich an, warum man das macht.
Ich mein, man kann für alles eine extra Funktion machen, aber wozu?
Wozu?
Ich habe mal einen Talk gesehen, das habe ich schon 5-5 Mal erzählt oder so,
über irgendein Ruby on Rails best practice Ding.
Da habe ich mir vor Jahren mal angeguckt und der Typ in diesem Conference Talk meinte,
für ihn sind alle seine Methoden zu lang, wenn sie mehr als eine Zeile haben.
Da habe ich auch gedacht, wie soll das funktionieren?
Besteht dann sein Source Code 90% als Spoilerplate für Funktionsdefinition oder was?
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Ganz im Ernst, manche Leute sind wirklich, genau,
einfach tausend Zeichenzeile machen.
Also manchmal sind auch diese Conference Talks übelster Bullshit.
Hast du das Video hier I quit Linus Tech Tips schon gesehen?
Nee, aber warum?
Ach, das ist ein anderer Dude.
Keine Ahnung.
Irgendeiner, der bei Linus aufhört, ja okay.
Soll er machen.
Juckt mich nicht.
Stinkender Code.
Also das ist ganz einfach.
Man muss einfach nur möglichst Agile sein.
Dann ist man schon weg, bis es anfängt zu stinken.
Ich glaube eigentlich, aber wir können auch was gucken.
Danach muss ich Pippo Fett machen.
Okay, was sollen wir?
Sie sollen uns das wenden.
Das ist so lang, 16 Minuten.
Was will er uns denn da erzählen?
Billige Windows Keys, tausende Strafverfahren laufen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil wir irgendwelche Leute vom LKW geklaute Lizenz Keys verkauft haben oder so.
Ein Mann von uns, der hat letztens einen Windows 10 Lizenz Key gekauft.
Und so sah der Kauf aus.
2,50 Euro hat er gezahlt bei Ebay.
Okay, 2,50 Euro.
Wobei, was kostet der Crempel aktuell?
Also bei Microsoft selbst muss man nicht gucken.
Da kostet es 400 Euro oder sonst was.
Aber ganz im Ernst, guck mal, war Amazon.
Windows 11 Key.
9,90 Euro.
Also das bewegt sich alles in...
Okay, 2,50 Euro mag halt schon billig sein, aber sonst ist es auch nicht so super teuer.
Lidl, Lidl hat Keys...
Lidl hat früher mal Lizenz Go oder so hießen die Dinger verkauft.
Ja, Lidl hat Office Keys mal verkauft.
Da kannst du doch auch nicht erwarten, dass derjenige, die Oma, die im Lidl das gekauft hat,
die weiß doch nicht, wo die Keys herkommen.
Egal, wir gucken jetzt das Video erst mal.
Warum sind die Preise so krass unterschiedlich?
Weil Microsoft selbst halt den Kram für einen vollen Preis bezahlt,
aber irgendwelche Reseller und OEM Keys und hast du nicht gesehen,
das billiger bezahlen. Aber eigentlich muss dich das als Endkunde ja nicht interessieren.
Woher sollst du das wissen?
Ich bin mal gespannt, was in dem Video rauskommt.
Es gibt die überall, es gibt die auch bei G2A, findest du auch.
Für die mache ich keine Werbung mehr und ich empfehle es auch keinem,
mit denen was großartig zu tun zu haben. Aber da kriegst du auch Windows Keys.
Windows Keys kriegst du da auch.
Du kriegst Windows Keys eigentlich mittlerweile überall.
Diesen Windows 10 Lizenz Key, die 2,50 Euro, kam ihm nachher aber sehr teuer zu stehen,
denn er hatte nachher eine Strafanzeige am Hals wegen.
Als Käufer?
Geldwäsche und Urheberrechtsverletzung, das ist ein Strafverfahren...
Moment, Geldwäsche? Krass, 2,50 Euro gewaschen.
Ja, das ist ja ganz schön kriminell.
... am Hals wegen.
Zwei für 2,50 Euro, Alter, what the fuck?
... die dann an den Mandanten geladen haben, was man tun kann...
... und Urheberrechtsverletzung, das ist ein Strafverfahren...
Was?
... heftig bestraft wird und ob euch das auch passieren kann und was man tun kann.
Und vor allen Dingen, was wir hier für den Mandanten getan haben,
zeige ich euch in diesem Fall, der einfach mal aus der Praxis stammt,
ich zeige euch auch die Streit der Polizei...
Alter, bei anderen Sachen wird gescampt im Millionenbereich und es juckt keine Sau.
... die dann an den Mandanten gelangt sind und natürlich, ja, wie die Rechtslage ist.
Also bleibt dran.
Und irgendein Dude, der auf Ebay ein Windows Key kauft?
What the fuck?
... selbst ein solches Verfahren am Hals.
Ich erinnere mich, das habe ich damals geschockt, das Video zu...
... wegen Urheberrechtsverletzung am Hals, weil eine Sekretärin von mir
ein Windows-Lizenz-Key für die Kanzlei gekauft hatte
und es stellte sich nachher aus, die Keys waren geklaut oder automatisch generiert
oder was auch immer.
Und hier sieht man, schon fast ein Jahr ist es her,
aber so lange dauern manchmal Verfahren, dass man dann von uns am 27. März 2020...
Was war denn das gerade für ein Sound, Leute?
Habt ihr das auch gehört?
Du.
... ein Windows-Lizenz-Key für die Kanzlei gekauft hatte...
Das war bestimmt ein Video.
... und es stellte sich nachher aus, die Keys waren geklaut oder automatisch generiert
oder was auch immer.
Und hier sieht man, schon fast ein Jahr ist es her,
aber so lange dauern manchmal Verfahren, dass man...
Okay, das ist ein Video.
Da ist ein Sound im Video.
MonkaS.
... von uns am 27. März 2020 für 2,50 Euro hier einen Windows-10-Lizenz-Key gekauft.
Und dieser Kauf kam ihm jetzt, wenn man so will, teuer zu stehen,
denn die Staatsanwaltschaft hat gegen ihn ermittelt wegen Geldwäsche.
Und das Schreiben, was dann ihn seitens der Polizei erreicht hat,
das habe ich euch auch mit...
Übrigens, was da teilweise läuft, ist auch der Wahnsinn.
Ein Kollege auf der Arbeit hat mir erzählt, er hat einen Brief bekommen,
das Verfahren gegen ihn wurde eingestellt.
Und er denkt sich so, welches Verfahren?
Was wollen die von mir?
Aber sein Name stimmte.
Sein Name war richtig.
Und dann ist er zur Polizei und hat gesagt, was für ein Verfahren?
Was ist gegen mich?
Was sprecht ihr überhaupt?
Und dann hat sich rausgestellt, dass irgendjemand festgenommen wurde
und der hat bei der Festnahme keinen Ausweis dabei gehabt.
Und er hat seinen Namen und seine Adresse gesagt bei der Festnahme.
Und es hat danach nie jemand wirklich überprüft, ob das der Typ ist.
Und irgendwann bekommt er dann einen Brief, das Verfahren gegen sie wurde eingestellt.
Das sah wie folgt aus, das ist die Polizei sagt, schriftliche Äußerung als Beschuldigter.
Ihnen wird vorgeworfen, folgende Straftaten begangen zu haben.
Straftaten nach dem Urheberrechtsgesetz, sonstiger Verstöße ohne Softwarepiraterie und Geldwäsche.
Aber Geldwäsche bei 2,50 Euro?
Dann wird gesagt, Ihnen wird nach der Strafprozessordnung 163a Strafprozessordnung
Gelegenheit gegeben, sich als Beschuldigte zu äußern.
Und bei dem Merkungen, das ist noch ganz spannend, Kauf sowie gegebenenfalls Download, Installation,
Nutzung des Betriebssystems Windows Same Professional über Ebay
vom nicht autorisierten Verkäufer mit dem Nickname so und so zu einem Preis deutlich unter Marktwert.
Wir waren gerade auf Amazon, bei Amazon kostet 9,99 Euro.
Sind jetzt 2,50 Euro so krass unter Marktwert, wenn es 9,99 Euro auf Amazon kostet?
Hier hast du deutlich unter Marktwert einen entsprechenden Windows 10 Lizenzkey gekauft.
Und das funktioniert doch gar nicht.
Das wollen wir uns mal anschauen.
Man kann sich übrigens immer noch, wobei ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich immer noch der Fall ist.
Aber man konnte sich Windows 7 Lizenzkeys kaufen und die damit immer noch aktivieren.
Die gibt es gar nicht mehr zu kaufen.
Moment, diesen Shit gibt es noch?
Nero 2014, Leute.
Oh man.
Sauber sind wir stehen geblieben.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut heute, weil ich so hoch gedreht habe, den Sound.
Die Kollegin Schasert hat den Mandanten hier vertreten, die es spezialisiert auf Strafrecht
und hat sich zunächst einmal, und das will ich jetzt hier mit euch auch machen, angeschaut,
was kostet denn normalerweise so ein Windows 10 Lizenzkey?
Denn das war auch das, was die Staatsanwaltschaft hier gesagt hat, kann man noch nicht machen,
dass man Windows 10 Lizenzkeys so günstig anbietet.
Na ja, und dann sieht man jetzt hier, ich habe es einfach nur mal gemacht,
Windows 10 Pro Key und am rechten Rand seht ihr Google Shopping-Ergebnisse.
5,95 Euro, 5,99 Euro, 5,50 Euro, mal 13 Euro, sogar bei Amazon 9,99 Euro und so weiter.
Das heißt also, das muss man jetzt hier erst einmal sagen,
der man dann sah, diese günstigen Preise und dachte so, na ja, gut, 5,99 Euro,
wenn ich es offiziell hier kaufe, aber 2,90 Euro, wenn ich es bei eBay kaufe,
habe ich doch ein Schnäppchen gemacht und eBay ist ja für Schnäppchen bekannt.
Dann ging es weiter, wir haben in der Verteidigung uns auch mal angeschaut,
jetzt könnte man ja noch immer sagen, dass das Ganze zu teuer war.
Was macht ein offizielles Portal darauf, wie Ideale, und die sagen 3,94 Euro kostet.
Also Chet sagt, das bei Amazon wäre auch illegal, aber mal ganz im Ernst,
selbst wenn das, also ich maße mir nicht an, das überhaupt einschätzen zu können,
noch gehe ich davon aus als Käufer, dass bei Amazon illegale Sachen verkauft werden.
Da muss ich doch von ausgehen, wenn das offiziell über Amazon verkauft wird,
also nicht Amazon, wenn das bei Amazon angeboten wird, sei es auch nur über den Marketplace,
dass das okay ist, dass ich mich nicht weiter über die Hintergründe beschäftigen muss, oder?
Also ich meine, es kann doch nicht sein, dass ich jetzt erst mal zwei Wochen nachforschen muss,
wo kommen die Keys her, bevor ich mir bei Amazon was kaufen kann.
Gehst du davon aus, dass auf eBay illegale Sachen verkauft werden? Nee, gehe ich auch nicht auf,
aber ganz ehrlich, auf eBay noch eher als bei Amazon, aber da würde ich bei eBay auch nicht von ausgehen.
Microsoft Windows 10, gut, das ist aber was anderes, das ist aber was anderes,
das kannst du so nicht vergleichen, bei den Windows Keys geht es ja nicht darum,
dass das irgendwie ein illegales Symbol oder sowas wäre, was ich da nicht rumzeichne,
sondern dass du quasi die Hintergründe kennen musst, wo hat er den Kram her,
so eine Reichsflagge oder irgendwie eine Flagge mit einem SS-Symbol drauf oder so,
das sind illegale Symbole, die darf ich nicht kaufen, die darf ich auch nicht,
oder weiß ich nicht, ob ich die kaufe, zumindest öffentlich zeigen darf man sie nicht,
und ob jetzt der Key illegal ist oder nicht, das sehe ich dem Key ja nicht an,
das ist so, wie wenn ich rausbekommen müsste, wenn ich einen Pulli kaufe,
ob der irgendwo unter illegaler Kinderarbeit hergestellt wurde oder nicht,
das kannst du jemand auch nicht kaufen, das kannst du jemand auch nicht verlangen,
dass der sich bei einem Kauf von einem Pulli informiert, von welcher Farm der kommt,
die Wolle und in welcher Fabrik der genäht wurde, nur um dann einsetzen zu können,
da wurde vielleicht in der Kette mal was Illegales gemacht, das kannst du doch gar nicht erwarten.
Also auch da wiederum, offizielles Portal, hatte der Mandant hier verglichen,
also hier ganz viele Preise, 3,94 €, 3,94 €, 3,94 €, 4,90 €,
sprich überall wird ein Windows 10 Pro Lizenz Key nachgeschmissen für 3,93 €,
das heißt, wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft hier sagt, Windows 10 Pro ist etwas,
was normalerweise 249 € kostet, dann kann man relativ...
Lass uns jetzt auch mal kurz gucken, Windows 10, sogar das ist teurer geworden,
guck mal, hier sind wir schon bei 1,20 €.
Zügig sagen, das sieht mir aber nicht so aus, wenn ich hier Microsoft Windows 10 Pro suche bei Idealo,
da kosten die Dinger eben nur irgendwas zwischen 2,50 € und...
Ja gut, aber Samstagnachmittag, das ist ja der Unterschied.
Das ist ja nicht okay, dass die Hersteller komisches Zeug verkaufen,
aber im schlimmsten Fall kannst du halt dein Windows Key nicht aktivieren
und Microsoft sagt, die nehmen den Key nicht,
aber dass dir da jetzt einer irgendwie den Strick draus drehen will, dass du den Key gekauft hast,
das kannst du doch überhaupt nicht einschätzen im Vorfeld.
Vielleicht, wenn du dich Monate, Jahre lang schon mit dieser Materie beschäftigst
und du anhand des Angebots erkennst, ah, das muss wahrscheinlich illegal sein.
Okay, aber doch nicht der 0a15-User, der auf Amazon nach einem Key sucht,
da zu einem Shop geht und dort den Key kauft.
Das kann der doch überhaupt nicht wissen und einschätzen.
Muss er doch eigentlich auch gar nicht.
So, deswegen mal gucken, was jetzt hier rauskommt, bin ich mal gespannt.
Ah, Leute, ich habe zu viele Tabs.
Wie weit ging es jetzt hier? 5 Euro, ja, so, da endet es schon.
Das heißt, die 2,50 Euro sind ein Schnäppchen sicherlich,
weil bei Diallo war es jetzt die 3,94.
Ja, aber so weit weg von 2,50, ist das nicht?
Unlogisch wäre das, muss man an dieser Stelle sicherlich auch sagen.
Wozu führte das?
Das führte dazu, dass unser Mandant keinerlei Verdacht schöpfte,
als er da zugeschlagen hat.
Er hat diesen Lizenz-Key problemlos aktivieren können
und ist zwischenzeitlich auf Mac umgestiegen, brauchte den also gar nicht mehr,
hat also sich gar keine weiteren Gedanken dazu gemacht
und bis er dann irgendwann Post von der Polizei erhalten hat.
Wie wir ihn rausgehauen haben, sage ich euch gleich,
aber vielleicht ganz interessant für euch, solche Geschichten
habe ich auch in meinem neuesten Buch, was am 17. Mai erscheint,
der Taschenanwalt.
Wenigstens Self-Sellout.
Wenn ihr euch fotografiert mit eurem Handy,
seid ihr direkt bei Amazon 14.99 für das Buch Kosten.
Und da ist so alles drin, was ich hier in YouTube euch präsentiere,
die spannendsten Sachen in Kurzform, aber auch die spannendsten Sachen aus jetzt,
weiß nicht, was habe ich, 16, 17 Jahre Anwaltserfahrung
oder fast 18 schon, ja.
Da ist alles von der Geburt bis zum Tod, alles, was ihr wissen müsst.
Ja, dann macht ihr das ungefähr so lange, wie ich IT krempel.
Wir haben ja wahrscheinlich ungefähr im gleichen Alter angefangen.
Nur was komplett anderes.
Weil ich selber ja auch mal so ein Verfahren hatte.
Was ich ganz besonders spannend fand, ist in diesem Fall,
dass nicht nur wegen Urheberrechtsverletzung ermittelt worden ist,
sondern wegen dem Geldwäsche.
Geldwäsche, das ist heftig, oder?
Stell dir mal vor, du denkst nichts Böses,
und auf einmal kriegst du einen Brief wegen Geldwäsche heim.
Das ist in die Erwägung reingezogen worden.
Hier wäre ein Gegenstand, der aus einer rechtswidrigen Tat herrührt.
Krasser Scheiß, Alter.
Nimm mal Nummer drei.
Sich oder einem Dritten verschafft.
Also ein Gegenstand, der aus einer rechtswidrigen Tat herrührt.
Und da sagt die Staatsanwaltschaft, na ja, die Keys wurden illegal beschafft.
Das hätte eine Ermittlung gegen einen Verkäufer ergeben.
Ja, aber das kannst du doch als Verkäufer nicht wissen.
Und dann begeht man eine Geldwäsche, wenn man sich so einen Gegenstand verschafft.
Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Ihr kauft jetzt hier einen Windows Key.
Ein Knast für 2,50 Euro.
Und steht mit einem Bein so krass im Knast, dass man eine Geldwäsche hat,
wo es heißt, fünf Jahre Gefängnis.
Dass dem Mandanten ziemlich die Hosenbeine schlotterten, war ja klar.
Das Problematische ist, wenn man sich jetzt hier den Tatbestand anschaut.
Wer einen Gegenstand, der aus einer rechtswidrigen Tat herrührt,
sich oder einem Dritten verschafft,
ist für fünf Jahre oder Geldstrafe bestraft.
Was machst du eigentlich? Ich habe mal eine blöde Frage.
Also wenn du dann zum Anwalt gehst, das kostet ja Geld.
Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, man ist plus minus null am Ende des Monats auf dem Konto.
Man hat kein Geld.
Also sagen wir mal, man gehört zu denen, die halt so vom, wie sagt man so,
vom Konto in den Mund legen, also von plus minus null im Konto.
Also stell dir vor, ihr seid jemand, der kein Geld hat.
Was macht man dann? Geht man an den Knast, weil man sich keinen Anwalt leisten kann?
Oder kann ich irgendwo dafür auch irgendwie Prozesskostenbeihilfe oder so beantragen?
Oder was mache ich denn da? Ja, okay, aber trotzdem.
Tat, das war eine illegale Kiesärztin, die verschafft fünf Jahre.
Das müsste man ja jetzt erst mal so sehen und sagen, ob Pech gehabt hat.
Jetzt ist es allerdings im Strafrecht, glücklicherweise muss man an dieser Stelle so,
dass wir hier einen sogenannten objektiven Tatbestand haben.
Das ist das, was da steht.
Er hat sich einen Gegenstand verschafft.
Das sind die Lizenskis, die stammen auch aus einer rechtswidrigen Tat.
Dass das objektiv so passiert. Ja, Haken dran.
Zum Glück ist es im Strafrecht noch so, dass man auch noch so einen sogenannten
subjektiven Tatbestand hat.
Jetzt kommt Anwaltlogik.
Man muss nicht nur das umgesetzt haben, was da passiert ist,
sich nämlich einen Gegenstand aus einer rechtswidrigen Tat verschafft haben.
Nein, man muss das auch wollen.
In seinen Gedanken musste unser Mandant das wollen.
Der wusste das aber gar nicht.
Das nennt man Vorsatz, diesen subjektiven Teil nennt man Vorsatz.
In diesem subjektiven Teil im Vorsatz gibt es Abstufungen.
Bei MMOGA ist das bestimmt derselbe Fall.
Ich glaube nicht, ob das einen Unterschied macht, ob eBay oder MMOGA.
Da muss man das gewusst und gewollt haben, dass der Lizenskier aus einer rechtswidrigen Tat stammt.
Das war hier definitiv nicht so.
Woher sollte er es wissen?
Ja, ist klar.
Es gibt aber noch den sogenannten Eventualvorsatz.
Da geht es darum, dass man für möglich gehalten hat, die illegalen Haken.
Okay, was kommt denn jetzt raus am Ende?
Weil es doch so günstig war.
Was kommt denn jetzt raus?
Die U-Uberrechtsverletzung, wo er sich einen Key gekauft hat.
Einen Key, einen Käufer.
Und dem wird jetzt die U-Uberrechtsverletzung vorgeworfen.
Also er hat nichts verbreitet, er hat nichts öffentlich wiedergegeben.
Das sind ja hier diese beiden Optionen.
Berechtigt ein Werk oder vervielfältig verbreitet oder öffentlich wiedergegeben.
Also er hat nichts verbreitet, er hat auch nichts öffentlich wiedergegeben.
Also bleibt nur die Vervielfältigung.
Und da ist es leider so, muss man sagen, das sagen die Gerichte,
das Installieren der Software, allein das Installieren der Software
ist schon eine u-überrechtliche Vervielfältigung.
Wait a minute, ich kann Windows auch komplett ohne Key installieren.
Und weil der Lizenzkey aus einer illegalen Tat stammt, ist die Verwendung unzulässig.
Also deswegen kann man nicht sagen, man kann auch darüber diskutieren,
ob es eine private Kopie ist.
Da geht es darum, dass es nicht offensichtlich rechtswidrig war.
Da wird dann über die offensichtliche Rechtswidrigkeit diskutiert.
Das kommt auch noch hinzu.
Aber auch hier wieder objektiv, ich habe euch das ja gerade erklärt mit dieser Objektivität.
Objektiv ist die Tat natürlich begangen worden.
Rein subjektiv, muss man sicherlich sagen, wusste der auch hier nicht,
dass er eine Tat begangen hat, die strafbar ist, weil er natürlich dachte,
naja, ich zahle doch dafür, ich kaufe dafür und zwar zahle ich einen angemessenen Preis.
Was ist denn jetzt rausgekommen am Ende?
Und gesagt, Entscheidung nach 170 Absatz 2 Strafprozess.
Was ist denn jetzt rausgekommen?
Auch wegen CD, das war damals glaube ich nur Windows XP, es gibt einfach so viele.
Aber man sieht natürlich, man hat ihn auch wieder rausgebockt und hier war es die Staatsanwaltschaft,
die das dann eingesehen hat.
Sie haben das Staatsanwaltschaft geschrieben, es ist Blödsinn und die haben gesagt,
das war ein bisschen viel, alles klar.
Beim Verkäufer selbst, klar, der kommt vermutlich ins Gefängnis,
der hat das also recht professionell bezahlt.
Ja, wenn du den Kram selbst anbiet, das ist ja klar, aber das ist ja schon heftig.
Dass die das so abgehen, da frage ich mich, haben die nichts besseres zu tun?
Auf der anderen Seite kann ich insofern auch verstehen,
es kann ja durchaus sein, dass es denen auch nicht wirklich bewusst war,
dass es irgendwie ein einzelner privater Typ ist und sie halt generell gerade gucken,
was da bei Keys abgeht und da halt auch mal was durch die Lappen geht,
dass es dann jemand trifft, der es eigentlich gar nicht verdient.
Schwer zu sagen, ich hätte jetzt gedacht, wir haben größere Probleme als private Leute,
die 2,50 Euro Windows Keys kaufen.
Mehr ist Windows ja auch nicht wert.
Dieses Jahr wird das Jahr vor Lilux als WSL vielleicht.
Weißt du, in Berlin hast du irgendwelche komischen arabischen Clans,
die da Zeug treiben, aber erst mal den 2,50 Euro Windows Key Benutzer,
der hat Geldwäsche.
Wann ist denn das Jahr von BSD? Immer, weil BSD zum Beispiel auf der Playstation läuft
oder auf... Wo läuft denn BSD noch?
Leute, es gibt zwei, drei Sachen, ganz bekannte Sachen, die auf BSD...
Mac OS hat BSD unten drunter, teilweise zumindest.
Ja, TrueNAS und sowas.
Nee, es gibt noch ein paar andere...
Allein schon, weil die Playstation auf BSD basiert, ist immer Jahr von BSD.
Aber wenn es danach geht, ist auch immer Jahr von Linux,
weil gefühlt, wenn du so rumguckst, 80% aller Geräte irgendwie auf Linux basieren.
Guckt euch die ganzen Android-Smartphones an, guckt euch irgendwelche Access-Points,
Router an, das ganze Internet wird ohne Linux nicht funktionieren,
also danach... Es ist aber wahrscheinlich nie das Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ich glaube, das werden wir nicht sehen.
Höchstens WSL.
Die dunkle Wahrheit über Matratzenkonkord.
Ist das dänisches Bettenlager? Nee, das war was anderes, oder?
Dänisches Bettenlager hat sich ja auch benannt.
Ja, ist jetzt unaufsprechbar, anders irgendwie.
Ok, zeig her.
Natürlich kennt ihr Matratzenkonkord.
Diese Läden...
Ja, jetzt wo ich das Logo sehe, kenne ich die auch.
Genau.
Jetzt, wenn ich das Logo sehe, kenne ich das auch.
An jeder Ecke in Deutschland, an jeder Ecke.
Bis vor kurzem gab es in Deutschland mehr Matratzenkonkord-Filialien als Burger King-Restaurants.
Herzhaft?
Wie kann das sein? Wer bitte kauft diese ganzen Matratzen?
Warum haben die immer Schlussverkauf? Warum sind diese Läden immer an Ecken?
Wer steckt hinter der Mist...
Stimmt, die sind immer an Ecken.
... das religiöseste und gleichzeitig omnipräsenteste Firma Deutschlands.
Was ist das Matratzenkartell und wie steckt Stiftung Warentest damit drin?
Fragen über Fragen.
Im August 2011 tritt das Bundeskartellamt auf den Plan und führt Razzien durch.
Hier sind fast alle Hersteller mit denselben Methoden unterwegs.
Matratzenkonkord, nach eigener Aussage Europas führender Fachhändler.
Matratzen werden überall geradezu reißerisch vermarktet.
Die zusichern, die sich bis zu 300 Prozent gewinnen.
Ja, das allein ist ja...
Das allein ist ja nicht verboten.
Es ist auch erlaubt, Scheiße zu verkaufen.
Ich meine, ich sag, passt mal auf.
War das bei Media oder war das bei Saturn?
Oder nee, irgendwo gab es VLC zu kaufen.
Letztens.
Shopping.
Irgendwo kann man VLC kaufen.
Wo man sich auch denkt, what? Warum?
Das kann man sich kostenlos im Internet besorgen.
Hier gibt es erstmal ein paar Spritzen, alles klar.
War das Media Markt?
Händler verkaufen, ja.
Also, Mist verkaufen oder kostenlose Sachen verkaufen ist ja erstmal nicht verboten.
Also generell sind das Sachen, solange die nicht verboten.
Du kannst Mist verkaufen.
Bevor es losgeht, kommen wir ganz kurz zum Sponsor des heutigen Videos.
Das ist mal wieder NordVPN.
Mit VPNs kann man virtuell seinen eigenen Standort ändern.
So kann man viele Geo-
Okay.
Erstmal über Scam reden und dann VPN-Anbieter.
Das ist ja ganz mein Geschmack.
Blockings umgehen und Inhalte aus anderen Ländern schauen bzw. lesen.
NordVPN ist super einfach zu bedienen.
Man sucht sich einfach auf einer Weltkarte aus, von wo aus man surfen will.
Klickt dann auf ein Land und schon ist es verboten.
Man surft schon noch von daheim aus.
Es gibt über 5200 Server in 60 Ländern. Davon sind mehr als 240 in Deutschland.
NordVPN ist auch deshalb superschnell.
Ihr werdet also keine Probleme mit eurer Verbindung haben.
Außerdem ist bei NordVPN seit neuestem auch ein zusätzlicher Bedrohungsschutz integriert.
Ohne extra Kosten, der zum Beispiel vor schädlicher Werbung schützen kann.
Das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren, wenn das HTTPS, wenn das TLS ist.
Mein VPN-Anbieter kann mein Traffic überhaupt nicht reingucken.
Unter nordvpn.com slash twoboardguys kriegt ihr einen exklusiven Deal auf einen 2-Jahresplan.
Außerdem gibt es einen Monat gratis dazu.
Wenn euch NordVPN nicht gefällt, gibt es eine 3-Jahre-
Gibt es eher per DNS-Blocking.
Gut, das funktioniert dann aber auch nur sehr eingeschränkt.
Gibt es einen guten Passwort Vault, den man selbst hosten kann?
Ja, Bitwarden-RS, was nicht mehr Bitwarden heißt, sondern Vaultkeeper-RS oder so.
Ist ganz okay.
Ansonsten nehmen Keepers.
Keepers kannst du nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen.
30 Tage Geld Zurückgarantie.
Bereits in den frühen 2000ern tauchten in diversen deutschen Untergrundforen-
Was ist an NordVPN so schlecht?
Es ist das gleiche oder nichts Schlimmes an sich.
Nur, dass die ganzen Versprechen der VPN-Anbieter, in dem Fall NordVPN,
in vielen Fällen ziemlich an der Realität vorbeigehen.
Wofür das gut ist, ist, was auch viele Leute machen,
Geo-Blocking umgehen bzw. irgendwelche Torrens runterladen,
ohne dass man den API sehen soll.
Aber selbst da fängt es schon an mit, lockt der wirklich nichts, was du machst.
Das weißt du ja nicht.
Du hast keine Ahnung.
Das sagen die Anbieter, ob das wirklich so ist und ob die das wirklich so machen,
wenn da mal die Polizei vor der Tür steht.
Das weiß man nicht.
Und ansonsten, es bringt halt auch in vielen Fällen nichts.
Du bist dadurch nicht wirklich anonymer oder verschlüsselter unterwegs als sonst.
Das Einzige, was verschlüsselt ist zusätzlich, ist die Verbindung von dir zum Anbieter.
Aber vom Anbieter zum Server, wenn es nicht hatte, TPS ist genauso wenig wie vorher.
Die Fragen zu Matratzen-Concord auf 2006 im GameStar-Forum.
Matratzenläden. Verschwörung.
Buzzfeed präsentiert einen Reddit-Kommentar,
der bei der Anzahl an Matratzenläden Geldwäsche von Kartellen nahelegt.
Auch bei der Welt stellt man sich bereits vor über zehn Jahren die Frage,
ob hinter Concord und Co. eventuell eine gewaltige Verschwörung stecke.
Moment. Geldwäsche.
Da musst du plus 2,50 Euro Mindowsky auf Ebay kaufen.
Irgendwann sind dann einige findige Journalisten von Business Insider auf das Thema gestoßen.
Das war 2018.
2018.
2018. Der betont das immer so wahnsinnig, als passiert jetzt gerade ganz, ganz, äh, schlimmes Zeug.
Der deutsche Deutsche kauft sich nur alle zehn Jahre eine neue Matratze.
Der Konzern schreibt Rote.
Dadurch, okay, da zähle ich nicht dazu.
Trotzdem gibt es Ende 2017 849 Filialien in Deutschland und es werden sogar noch mehr.
Die Journalistinnen von Business Insider gehen der Sache auf den Grund und sprechen mit Matratzen Concord Mitarbeitern.
Doch nicht mal die wissen, warum es die ganzen Läden ihres Unternehmens gibt.
Nicht mal, warum es den eigenen Laden gibt.
Ich zitiere.
Uns geht scheiße, sagt sie auf die Frage, wie das Geschäft laufe.
An manchen Tagen kommt niemand, an guten vielleicht zehn.
Heute hatte ich immerhin fünf Kunden.
Sie unterbricht kurz, um etwas auf ihrem Computer nachzuschauen.
350 Euro, sagt sie. Mehr Umsatz habe ich heute nicht gemacht.
Der Artikel...
Na, dann bräuchten die aber mal unbedingt den Verkaufscoach von vorhin.
... ist das Eckladen-Theorem auf.
Wenn man seinen Laden auf einer Ecke positioniert, hat man möglichst viele Schaufenster für die ganzen Rabattangebote.
Was ist, was ist da eigentlich los?
Ah, yes.
Ein Dude vom Matratzen-Startup Casper ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich abgefuckt von Matratzen Concord.
Die Shops von Matratzen Concord seien ein Sinnbild der Trostlosigkeit, Intransparenz und klarer Irreführung gegenüber dem Kunden, schimpft er.
Shish.
Mit dieser Kritik ist er natürlich nicht allein.
Und hier kommen wir zum Kern der Verschwörung.
Bis jetzt ist am nichts passiert.
Es gab in den 2000ern tatsächlich ein Matratzenkartell.
Das war ein vertikales Kartell und kein klassisches.
Das heißt, dass die verschiedenen Matratzenhersteller sich zwar nicht so untereinander abgesprochen haben,
aber der Preis einer Matratze eines Herstellers wurde verschiedenen Händlern nicht nur empfohlen, sondern aufgezwungen.
Wenn jemand eine bestimmte Matratze für günstiger verkauft hat als gewünscht, haben einige Hersteller zum Beispiel Lieferengpässe vorgetäuscht,
um diesen Händler dazu zu zwingen, wieder höhere Preise anzubieten.
Wir haben plötzlich ewig lange Lieferzeiten gehabt.
Also zum Teil 10, 15 Wochen.
Angeblich waren Matratzen plötzlich knapp bei Herstellern.
Also das kann nicht sein.
Das ist ein normaler Konsumgütartikel.
Da gab es auch einige richtig saftige Strafen vom Bundeskartellamt.
Das alles hat halt dazu geführt, dass Matratzen die Bank durch häufig viel zu teuer waren, weil es einfach keinen echten Preiswettbewerb gab.
In der Industrie gab es quasi eine 300%-Regel, heißt auf jede Matratze gibt es ungefähr 300% Gewinn.
Ja und? Also das ist doch schon olle Kamellen, oder?
Marge. Nicht schlecht?
Matratzen Concord war kein verurteilter Teil von diesem Kartell oder so, aber der Dauerschlussverkauf ist dennoch ein ziemlich fieser Trick.
Wenn ein Matratzenmodell in nur einem Laden einer Kette wie Matratzen Concord für ein paar Tage zu einem bestimmten Preis angeboten wurde, darf man danach mit einem Rabatt werben.
Also wenn eine Matratze in Buxtehude drei Tage lang 600 Euro gekostet hat, kann sie danach überall für 50 Euro angeboten werden mit einem 80%-Rabatt-Sheld.
In allen anderen Läden. Außerhalb von Buxtehude.
Auch.
Als Durchschnittsauto hat man natürlich überhaupt gar keine Ahnung, wie viel eine bestimmte Art von Matratze ungefähr kostet.
Guck mal da im Internet, oder man geht zum Ikea.
Und so schafft man diese Läden dann so ein Gefühl von, uuuh, Schnapper.
Ja, aber das ist doch nicht verboten, also da weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob das irgendwie jetzt, naja.
Aber jetzt kommt nach Dekaden der Stadtbild-Dominanz durch super transparente, perfekte, mega-kundenfreundliche Preisstrukturen augenscheinlich der Abstieg.
Die Konkurrenz aus dem Internet spitzt sich seit einigen Jahren zu.
Das klassische Matratzen-Game ist nicht mehr so profitabel.
Und in der eigenen Verzweiflung hat sich die Matratzenbranche vor einigen Jahren so richtig hart über Stiftung Warentest aufgeregt,
weil die die günstige Anti-Kartell-Matratze eines Online-Händlers immer wieder zum Testsieger erklären.
Der Matratzenverband hat der Stiftung dann vorgeworfen, so etwas shady richtig viel Cash mit den eigenen Siegeln zu machen
und quasi heimlich für die Anti-Kartell-Matratze zu werben.
Das hat sich die Stiftung wiederum nicht gefallen lassen und eine ultralange Stellungnahme gedroppt und dem Verband eine einstweilige Verfügung reingedrückt.
Das Matratzen-Game ist so, es ist alles so weird.
Naja, angeblich hat MC heute noch über 550 Filialien in Deutschland.
Aber wenn man auf der Karte raustun...
Na gut, man kann sich da sicherlich darüber streiten, ob das schöne Praktiken sind oder so.
Aber ist das jetzt die dunkle Wahrheit?
Nur 496, dementsprechend eine Textempfehlung für die Webseite von uns.
Nur 500 Läden, minus 40 Prozent.
Ha!
Das Unternehmen wird mittlerweile lieblos rumgereicht und wurde vor ein paar Jahren für 5 Millionen Euro von einem niederländischen Unternehmen an ein chinesisches verkauft.
Hätten David und ich eher gewusst, wie günstig so eine Kette ist, hätten wir den Laden für das bisschen Trinkgeld auch einfach selbst übernehmen können.
Wir brauchen im Ostflügel eh noch neue Matratzen für die Gästezimmer.
Naja, jetzt ist es zu spät.
Das war's. Ende der Verschwörung. Jetzt habt ihr endlich Antworten. Zumindest ein paar.
Hä?
Es ist natürlich immer...
Okay, das war jetzt eigentlich komplett sinnlos.
Die machen halt Dinger, die vielleicht Grauzonen ausnutzen, aber gut, man...
Ich weiß nicht, das hat mich jetzt nicht so geschockt.
Also ich weiß, die dunkle Wahrheit und diese Anfangs mit Geldwäsche und Gedüllensatz kam ja auch nichts mehr.
Keine Ahnung, Alter.
Naja.
Ja, ich frag mich, ich frag mich bei vielen Sachen, warum sie erlaubt sind.
Ja, aber das ist ja gar nicht der Punkt.
In dem Fall scheint es ja in Ordnung zu sein.
Man kann sicherlich das fragwürdig finden, aber deswegen ist es jetzt noch keine dunkle Wahrheit.
Dunkle Wahrheit wäre jetzt gewesen, wenn das wirklich irgendwelche Mafialäden wären für Geldwäsche oder so.
Das habe ich mir schon angeguckt, das ist irgendeine WebAssembly-Preisengeschichte, die mega langsam ist.
Verstehe den Sinn davon wenig.
Kann ich auch.NET im Browser machen, was ich auch nicht mache, weil es ewig lädt.
Keine Ahnung.
Nur weil manche Sachen gehen, weiß ich nicht, ob sie sinnvoll sind.
Ganz ehrlich, das hat sich doch von alleine erledigt.
Die Leute kaufen den Kram im Internet, weil sie keinen Bock mehr haben auf solche shady Läden, wo du nicht durchblickst.
So muss das sein.
Also ich habe meine letzte Matratze bei Ikea, glaube ich, gekauft.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Leute, ich habe euch Mist erzählt, das ist falsch.
Die vorletzte habe ich bei Ikea gekauft, die aktuelle habe ich im Internet bestellt.
Natürlich die aktuelle habe ich im Internet bestellt, die davor habe ich bei Ikea gekauft.
Ja, wäre auch komisch, ich habe fast alles im Internet bestellt.
Leute, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich habe Hunger.
Pilpo Fett.
Alles klar.
Chat, ich weiß, ihr mögt das immer, wenn ich den Stream so schnell beende.
Wisst ihr, andere Leute machen Outro, haben Outro-Song, der läuft, verabschieden sich 10 Minuten.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen, macht es gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.